Guten Morgen. Guten Morgen Tim.
Ach so langsam habe ich mich auch eigentlich dran gewöhnt.
Logbuch, Netzpolitik Nummer zweihunderteinundvierzig vom zweiten Februar zweitausendundachtzehn. Komm mal mit Datum, geil, oder?
Ja, gehört sich so, das äh müssen wir das verkacken wir nur normalerweise immer.
Ich hab's mir jetzt ein bisschen antrainiert.
Ja und klappt, ist ein ganz neues Gefühl, so zeitlich orientiert sein zu müssen, ne? Was haben wir heute für einen Tag? Was gab's gestern zum Mittag.
Ja. Das sind doch Details. Nach Wochentagen und Essen fragt doch am Ende keiner.
Setzen wir die mit auseinander.
Na ja, auf jeden Fall ist jetzt hier die Überbrückungsveranstaltung hier mit erstmal beendet, wir machen jetzt weiter und haben auch wilde Pläne,
Euch, wie gewohnt, mit Interpretation des Zeitgeschehens zu versorgen.
Was heißt Interpretation? Das wird nicht interpretiert, das wird hier erklärt, wie es ist. Und warum wir Recht haben.
Ja wie halt so ein interpreter äh der übersetzt einem ja auch irgendwie was in komischen Sprachen gesprochen wird und so machen wir das auch.
Interpreta, ah ja.
Irgendwo. Das war jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen um die E.
Das erinnert mich an diese, hast du eigentlich diese ähm Nummer mitbekommen von den äh beruflichen Übersetzern, die sich dann über die skandalösen Bedingungen beim CCC äh echauffiert haben?
Ja, habe ich mitbekommen.
Ja, ich meine, gut, das ist sicherlich ähm also was passiert ist, ist das so ein Berufsverband, der Besitzer sich sozusagen darüber,
erregt hat, dass äh ja so viele Ausbeutung äh stattfindet auf dem Kongress, wo dann die armen Übersetzer da kostenlos arbeiten müssen.
Ich glaube der Hintergrund ist, dass die sich in dieser Tätig, in diesem Tätigkeitsbereich grundsätzlich über sehr viel ausbeutung und schlechte Bedingungen.
Dass sie da quasi ein Auge für haben.
Ja, das ist sicherlich auch.
Das kann ich auch sehr gut, das kann ich sehr gut nachvollziehen und das, wenn sie dann, dass sie sich dann eben ärgern, wenn da Laien ihre schöne Arbeit machen, aus reiner Begeisterung und Freude.
Also ich hatte nicht so den Eindruck, dass ihr auch wirklich wirklich nur ansatzweise verstanden haben, was eigentlich da auf dem Kongress die äh Realität ist. Von daher äh kann man das vielleicht auch nachsehen.
Sonst kommen demnächst die Netzwerktechniker, die Veranstaltungstechniker, die Projektleiter, die Tresenkräfte, äh die die äh Handelsfachpacker,
macht halt niemand beim Kongress Geld, muss man halt mit leben. Aber fand ich, fand ich,
glaub die haben sich ja dann auch irgendwie wieder vertragen. Das wurde ja nur.
Man muss halt manchmal einfach ein bisschen erklären und interpretieren und dann.
Dann geht das halt auch gleich wieder, ne? Das probieren wir ja hier auch.
Wir sind immer sehr bemüht. Wir waren stets bemüht.
Genau, wir bemühen uns.
Genau, der lassen wir das. Ähm ich würde ganz schnell diesmal weil ich ja so lange nicht Podcast habe, einmal zu Beginn der Sendung ganz kurz den,
den Dank aussprechen.
Um erstmal reinzukommen.
Um einfach mal reinzukommen, ich bitte, ich bin ja gerade schon reingekommen. Ich bin noch reingekommen in die Meta-Ebene. Es ging.
Hier warteten aber einige sehr sehr liebe Überraschungen auf mich,
und ich hab mich da sehr sehr drüber gefreut und es ist immer wieder erschreckend, dass teilweise ich muss glaub ich mal aufhören,
Auf dieser Wunschliste einfach Sachen, die ist ja so eine Merkliste für mich, sodass ich sage,
Wenn ich dann mal irgendwann Geld überhabe, dann kaufe ich mir das.
Man kann die Merkliste auch nicht öffentlich schalten, ne.
Es gibt auch eine, es gibt auch eine, man gibt da eine andere, ne, aber gut, jetzt äh,
Also vielen, vielen herzlichen Dank. Das hat mir nach äh dieser Pause, die ich mir auch zwangsverordnet habe äh sehr viel ein ein sehr schönes, herzliches äh Zurückwillkommen
bereitet und jetzt hier mit Freuden neuer Energie an die in die in den Morast zu rein.
Und zwar äh Alex, Björn, Christian, Christine Fabian, Heiko Christopher, Hans-Georg, Jean-Johannes,
Marion Max, Niklas, Sebastian Tobias Wiebke, Wolfgang und mehreren ungenannten, damit,
Hier noch einmal wirklich vielen herzlichen Dank und wenn euer Name nicht dabei war, dann äh schreibt mir doch ruhig einfach nochmal,
Wobei ich sagen muss, dass das nie jemand bisher getan hat, wenn ich dazu aufgerufen wurde. Doch ganz wenige Male. Das heißt, ihr seid alle sehr ähm Privatsphäre bewusst, wohl einen Aluhut auf oder was?
Nur die besten.
Also da nein, sehr schön, vielen, vielen Dank und ähm mich sehr gefreut. Tim nicht,
Der hat hier die ganze Bude vollständig. Nein, so viel war's auch nicht.
Ach, das das hier rumsteht, das äh kratzt mich nicht. Aber die ganze Zeit so Filialen zu rennen in von totaler Erwart.
Boah mein neues Sketch, der hat.
Passt schon.
Also vielen, vielen herzlichen Dank. Kongress war auch gewesen. Für mich ist das ja jetzt die erste Sendung nach dem Kongress. Ja. Und ähm.
Ja, für uns ist das ja schon irgendwie aus den Augen aus dem Sinn.
Aus, wenn irgendwas im Sinn, sowas, sowas vergisst man noch nicht. Äh ich.
Ja, aber man hört auf, darüber zu reden. Ich bin schon wieder, ich bin schon beim nächsten Kongres.
Ja, ich bin. Du bist schon beim nächsten Kongress.
Zwar schon lange, also ich bin eigentlich schon seit dem zweiten Tag des Kongresses.
Subscribe oder oder der der tatsächlich.
Der Kongress, also ich fange eigentlich mit einem ersten Kongresstag an, mir Gedanken über den nächsten Kongress zu machen, weil das ist immer so ein bisschen so mein Part äh irgendwie schon erfüllt so. Ist so ein Hobby von mir.
Ich würde ich habe ja auch eine Selbstverständlichklopfbuchnetzpolitik gehört im Exil. Ähm,
der ich würde gerne nochmal ein paar Vorträge ganz kurz hier empfehlen, einfach nur, weil ich nicht, weil ich nicht weiß, ob ob ihr die äh in der vollen Blüte gewürdigt habt, wie wie es diesen Vorträgen gebührt. Ähm,
ein wirklich großartiger.
Du hast zugehört.
Nicht, vielleicht kann ich,
Also ein ein Vortrag der äh der den ihr glaube ich auch nicht erwähnt hattet und der aber wirklich ähm sehr sehr gut war,
ist der zu links unten Punkt in die Media Punkt org. Äh wo die Anwältin äh der,
dieses als Verein,
ja verbotenen Betreiberkollektivs sich dazu geäußert, hat was von diesem Fall zu halten, ist wieder und was da, also hat er einen sehr, also sehr guten juristischen Einblick äh
gegeben in die Gesetze, enorm äh gut erklärt.
Und aber auch natürlich den Gesellschaftenlichen Blick darauf, was da eigentlich gerade passiert, nämlich, dass diese Leute da eine Plattform bereitgestellt haben, wo andere.
Inhalte einstellen konnten,
ja? Und die sich zunächst einmal selbstverständlich ihre Kontrolle entziehen und das ist eben bisher die, ne, dass da tatsächlich Bekennerschreiben von äh irgendwelchen ähm,
Linksradikalen Aktionen oder
Anschlägen oder wie auch immer man das dann nennen darf, formuliert wurden. Ja, das ist richtig, aber äh man eben auch natürlich argumentieren kann, es ist natürlich
trotzdem ein öffentliches Interesse daran gibt und ja durchaus äh große Beschwerden gab von Seiten der Inlandsgeheimdienste äh dass äh dieses Links unten ihn eigentlich sehr gut geholfen hat bei ihrer Arbeit. Ähm.
Großartiger Vortrag muss man gesehen haben und sei es nur äh
wenn aufgrund der Schilderung, was das für die Beschuldigten jetzt bedeutet an Gerichtskosten, an Anwaltskosten, was da für für Geld, für Einschränkungen und so mit einhergehen, wenn man,
tatsächlich in einer solchen Situation ist und da vergeht einem sehr schnell das Lachen, ja? Alle Geräte weg und,
also unglaublich muss man, muss man sich ähm,
Sollte man unbedingt gesehen haben, weil er noch dazu eben ein besonders guter Vortrag ist, so großartige Folien, großartig strukturiert, großartig erklärt, ganz, ganz toll.
Habe ich auch äh dann gesehen, aber ich glaube auch erst dann im äh Nachgang, die Liste war ja auch lang und ich könnte das unterstreichen, dass das auf jeden Fall ein einer der äh einer der Hacken ist, die man machen sollte an diesem Kongress.
All Computers A beschlagnahmt und die
Anwältin heißt Christin und den Nachnamen kann ich nicht aussprechen. Ich war auch der Koordinator von dem Talk und ich hatte auch mit. Ich hab sie auch da getroffen, wir haben uns auch unterhalten, also bitte nimm's mir nicht übel, der Nachn,
Ja, das war ich, als ich da in der Kanzlei angerufen habe, war das auch so ein bisschen so ich hätte gerne die Frau ja, ich weiß.
Also großartiger Vortrag.
Mhm.
Der glaube ich auch noch viel mehr Aufmerksamkeit verdient als er bisher hatte? Dann äh immer großartig ist sowieso Arne Semeshord, klar.
Jedes Jahr da, jedes Jahr sagen wir ihm letzte Mal,
Wir wollen nicht immer nur deine Vorträge, ja? Du musst dich auch mal musst auch mal einfach keinen geilen Vortrag einreichen. Hier hat Zock direkt wieder. Ähm großartiger Vortrag. Ähm.
Hooligans.
Schreibtisch Hooligans, genau, großartig.
Den habe ich tatsächlich noch nicht gesehen. Zimmer.
Auch wirklich, also einer der also wirklich ja die sind alle geil, ja? Michael Kreil.
Social Bots.
Den hatten wir aber schon erwähn.
Blasen. Ja, aber da habt ihr einfach nur, ihr habt erwähnt. Der dieser Vortrag ist einfach sowas von kühl seziert, diese ganze Debatte, ja? Also ich sag mal, der Höhepunkt des Vortrags beginnt ähm als er sagt,
Ich habe mich gefragt, wie machen das denn die Profis?
Da fängt der Vortrag an äh so sein volles Potential zu entfalten, ähm denn,
Er hat sich da quasi die die Forschung angeschaut und hat einfach mal deren Methoden geprüft,
weil große, also ich meine dieses Thema Social Bots, wir hatten das ja auch im Jahresrückblick angesprochen,
hat's auch glaube ich hier im Logbuch gemerkt, dass mir das dann irgendwann tatsächlich aus dem aus dem Halse raushing und ich hab's aber immer so quasi unter der Prämisse noch diskutiert, dass diese Studien wenigstens stimmen und fachlich in Ordnung sind, wenn sie,
so viel tausend Boards,
und äh ja, Michael hat dann da mal in bei denen, die ihre Daten öffentlich gemacht haben und die, die ihre Kriterien nachvollziehbar gemacht haben, die mal angewendet und hat dann eben gezeigt, dass diese
dass sie noch nicht mal methodisch auch nur in der Nähe von von sauber ist diese Forschung und äh das ist glaube ich in seiner
Bedeutung sehr unterschätzt, was was der da wieder da eigentlich zu einer Debatte, die über anderthalb Jahre hier alle gequält hat, so vervollständigt den den Sinn und entrissen hat
großartig. Geil und vor allem so Kühl sitziert, ähm, toll.
Und ein Ergebnis unseres äh Aufrufs zu Twitter äh spenden.
Stimmt gut, dass du das sagst. Er dankt uns auch nochmal, denn diese Forschung, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer wurde,
Substanziell von euch ermöglicht, weil wir damals dazu aufgerufen hatten äh eure den API-Zugriff für Michael und sein Team zu ermöglichen und dadurch
hatte er die Möglichkeit so effektiv, um in dieser äh in dieser Menge,
Twitter, Social Bod Forschung zu betreiben und hat da auch nochmal ähm herzlich euch gedankt zum Beginn des Vortrages. Also das ist äh,
ganz klar der ausgeführt, ich gebe das nur wieder durch euch ermöglicht worden, der sollte da euch natürlich auch die Früchte eures Klicks mal,
die nochmal anschauen. Ganz toll.
Genau, könnte auch ein bisschen stolz sein auf euch. Mitmachen hilft.
Dann lange,
antizipiert und durchaus natürlich auch kontrovers unter einigen kommentiert worden der Auftritt der Auftritt des Zentrums für politische Schönheit, die mal wieder.
So gerockt haben.
Dir einfach wieder so gerockt haben. Also Stefan, gut, ich habe ihm das auch nach dem Vortrag schon gesagt. Die können einfach so einen Vortrag, ja,
Das ist ähm also der ist äh so schön, so sauber, so so
so geile Pointen drin, alles gescriptet, ja? Also und das heißt halt das will was heißen, ja? Wenn du halt, also wenn der dieser Vortrag ist einfach großartig und das muss man äh muss man muss man gesehen haben,
auch und vor allem wenn man ähm anderer Meinung zu äh zu deren Positionen oder sonstigen ist.
Sicher auch viel Streit an Annahmen äh,
aus äh sozusagen entzündet hat, ja wie sich dann herausgestellt haben, so nicht unbedingt gestimmt haben, also insbesondere private Überwachung,
war halt im Wesentlichen Inszenierung und allein daran kann man auch wieder schön sehen wie
stark auch das künstlerische Moment in in dieser ganzen Aktion ist, obwohl sie eben äh auch auch auch hochpolitisch ist und das finde ich halt einfach gut, das hatten wir ja auch schon mal, als wir das ausführlich diskutiert haben hier, glaube ich, beide
schon mehrmals zum Besten gegeben
auch wenn ich mich jetzt grad nicht mehr an das Detail erinnere, was mich so umgehauen hat, aber sie haben ja dann äh nicht nur jetzt nur über diesen Fall geredet, sondern sie haben ja sozusagen auch seit seit dem letzten Vortrag, den sie auf dem Kongress gehalten haben, mal so einen Diff gemacht, was sie seitdem alles noch so an Aktionen gemacht
haben, mir fällt's jetzt gerade nicht ein, aber da waren.
Diese Druckeraktion in der Türk.
Ja, ah ja genau ja sowas zum Beispiel ne, so mit Laserdrucker da äh ins Hotelzimmer stehen und dann erstmal ausreisen und dann irgendwie ihren Modeprintjob zu starten
Das das ist einfach auch einfach so von das hat einfach so einen Hacker äh Peel und finde ich passt von daher auch so wunderbar auf diesen
Kongress ist einfach toll, also bitte nochmal angucken, wenn ihr das noch nicht gemacht habt, ist echt ein Tipp.
Stefan und Philipp Bruch. Großartig. Habe also wisst ihr auch. Ähm da das wäre jetzt aus dem ich könnte jetzt noch in den anderen Tracks irgendwie äh soll ich.
Ja, warum nicht? Ich meine, dann.
Nee, komm, dann, dann,
ja kann ich auch, mach mal lieber nächstes Mal, mach mal nächstes Logbuch, machen wir einen anderen Track, dann sage ich, was ich in in anderen Tracks noch zu empfehlen habe. Das war jetzt so das, was zu, ihr habt ja schon in der letzten Sendung oder ne, in der vorvorletzten Sendung einiges empfohlen.
Ja gut, wir haben uns natürlich vor allem so auf diese ganzen unmittelbar jetzt politisch relevanten Sachen äh gestürzt.
Lass uns das mal ein bisschen strecken. Lass uns mal äh weitermachen. Wir werden noch Programm. Dann gehen wir in die anderen Tracks gehen wir zu anderen Zeiten.
Ähm dass das es ist immer so viel. Ich glaube man ich habe so ein bisschen Sorge. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das stimmt. Vielleicht könnt ihr das auch mal in den Kommentaren mitteilen,
Dieser Kongress, er schlägt dann immer alle, ja? Oh, der Kongress hat mich erschlankt, mich ja auch. Ich sowieso. Nicht am allermeisten. Mich hat der Kongress. Aber allerletzt, der Schla.
Niemand wird vom Kongress so erschlagen wie ich.
Wenn schon mit Trump apeal.
Die größte die größte wir hatten übrigens die größte Besucherzahl in der Geschichte des Kongresses. Ähm.
Man wird davon so erschlagen, aber dann.
Guckt man vielleicht noch so ein Bincht mal noch so ein bisschen nach, ja? Und dann ist aber auch schon wieder oh Scheiße irgendwie,
Februar muss mal wieder zur Arbeit oder so. Und hat dann vielleicht gar nicht alles gesehen, was was der Kongress an an Inhalt,
produziert hat auf den auf den Bühnen und in den in den ja auf den Bühnen, was wo es ja primär aufgezeichnet wird. Und äh,
Schade eigentlich. Deswegen würde ich da vielleicht einfach ein bisschen mehr dran erinnern, dass es sicher jetzt noch ein noch gute elf Monate bis zum nächsten Kongress könnte auch noch Alten gucken.
Also hier.
Der Alte ist noch nicht schlecht.
Ich kriege den Alten nie durchgeguckt bis zum nächsten.
Eben und dabei helfen wir jetzt, indem wir einzeln immer mal wieder an.
Verstehe er wird die sein. Kongress äh Forever sozusagen. Gut. Aber.
Du darfst jetzt auch nochmal die Gelegenheit nutzen, überhaupt mal einen Kommentar zu diesem Kongress abzulassen. Wenn du möchtest, also,
unabhängig jetzt mal äh rein von dieser Vortrags äh Geschichte, also,
Leipzig, neuer Ort, neue Herausforderungen. Kannst natürlich auch äh schweigen. Möchtest.
Ein äh Gentleman genießt und schweig.
Na gut.
Kaum bin ich weg, das war ihr aber auch klar, ne? Das war ja sowieso klar, wenn ich weggehe, dann bricht die Welt zu. Bricht die Welt zusammen.
Die Welt zusammen. Na klar.
Ähm und in diesem Fall wirklich also einmal alles äh nämlich Prozessor. Der Prozessor ist kaputt. Die.
Und zwar nicht nur einer, sondern eigentlich alle. Oder fast fast fast alle.
Eigentlich alle. Und wir haben uns jetzt gerade.
Mehr oder weniger spontan dazu entschieden, dass wir, dass ich versuchen werde für Laien zu schildern, grob, worin das Problem besteht. Nun werden.
Meine Freundinnen und Freunde, Experten und Expertinnen feststellen, dass ich das ein bisschen sehr verallgemeinere.
Moin. Kurzer Hinweis, worüber wir jetzt reden ist Toppunkt.
Meldung und Spector.
Genau, also die weit diskutierte, weit äh herumgereichte Sicherheitslücken, Kombinationen, die,
Kurz nach dem Kongress, ne? Wenige Tage irgendwie äh äh auf den Tisch kam und die doch eine ganze Menge Welle gemacht hat und zwar,
über den normalen da ist mal wieder was passiert mit Computern, Range hinaus,
Vielleicht ist es nicht unbedingt von allen so wahrgenommen worden, weil es für sie irgendwie dasselbe ist, wie heute Rancel, wo er dieses Sicherheitslücke da, fünfzigtausend äh Million,
Hacker äh Daten, Ausfälle, was nicht alles, also das das man hört es ja am laufenden Meter, aber so Every Ones in the Wile passiert ja auch mal was, was sozusagen mal so eine gewisse Epik äh auch noch hat, so die die sozusagen etwa
weiterträgt und weil dem so ist, ja, wollen wir dem halt hier auch nochmal so ein bisschen den Raum einreichen, also klar zu machen, wie so Madedown und Spector Sicherheitslücke,
ist kein kleines Ding. Und sie ist,
auch noch lange nicht vom Tisch, also selbst wenn's da heutzutage schon erste Maßnahmen gibt, ist noch gar nicht abzusehen, wie lange und wie umfangreich uns das noch so beschäftigen wird und äh deswegen ist das.
Das am Ende kosten wird.
Und was das alles auch noch so für Implikationen hat. Ich meine, ich sehe da auch sehr viele positive äh Folgen daraus, so, weil wenn wir gleich dann im Nachgang vielleicht nochmal diskutieren, was das so alles so für äh potenzielle Auswirkungen haben kann,
Aber zunächst einmal sollte man mal beschreiben, was eigentlich passiert ist. Hier ist ja etwas herausgefunden worden,
Gleich von mehreren Teams. Und es ist wohl auch in dem Zuge herausgekommen, dass das auch schon vor längerer Zeit auch schon mal aufge,
worden ist,
ich hab das jetzt im Detail nicht so verfolgt, aber da gab's wohl auch schon so in den neunziger Jahren schon erste Zweifel an diesem ganzen, die dann aber so
Wir brauchen Performance, äh die mir aus der Sonne äh mäßig so bearbeitet wurden, auch in der Zeit, wo sagen wir mal, dieser ganze Security-Aspekt auf Hardwareebene noch überhaupt gar keine Rolle gesp
Zumindest keine nennenswerte.
Ich versuch's mal zu erklären. Also ich versuche das jetzt für,
für nicht Prozessorarchitektur, Expertinnen und Experten zu erklären. Werde dabei vielleicht die ein oder andere Vereinfachung machen.
Ja, ich werd's vielleicht auch noch die Vereinfachung versuchen zur Vereinfachung. Genau, weil ich denke es.
Noch mehr vereinfachen. Aber lass mich doch mal anfangen.
Nee, nee, nee, ich äh ich weiß nur, ich habe ich ahne, auf welchem Level du einsteigst und ich denke, das ist manchmal sogar ganz gut äh wenn man jetzt wirklich uns ein ein,
ein Publikum adressieren, was sozusagen damit relativ selten in Drogen kommt. Einfach um mal klar zu machen so eure Computer bestehen ja aus verschiedenen Komponenten.
Und äh ein paar dieser Komponenten spielen jetzt hier eine besondere Rolle, nämlich so der Arbeitsspeicher.
Kennt man ja mal, da kauft man so Gigabytes von und man weiß, wenn man mehr davon hat, ist irgendwie besser.
Meisten Leute wissen, man kauft da man kriegt da irgendwie zwei Gigabyte von und in der Freakshow sagen sie immer, sie kaufen da mehr von.
Genau. Und natürlich der Prozessor, der sagen wir mal, sagen wir mal so
auch ein bisschen so die die Geburtsstunde auch des des des des der modernen Computerzeit waren
dass eben diese ganze Integration, von Logik auf so einem zentralen Chip, wo die Software draufläuft, das war schon so ein bisschen der Auslöser, also der Mikroprozessor, Anfang der,
Siebziger Jahre war das sozusagen das Ding so mit
kam das Ganze überhaupt so in diese Spur, das ist so die Zeit, wo das anfing und das hat dann eben schnell dazu geführt, dass eben so mit den äh mit dem Apple zwei, mit diesen ganzen frühen Home-Computern, Anfang der achtziger Jahre,
Eigentlich diese ganze äh Welle erst so richtig, diese ganze Revolution und dieses, wir bringen jetzt mal Computer in, an jeden Ort. Damit ist das eigentlich erst so richtig los äh gegangen und die die CPU ist,
nach wie vor die wichtigste Komponente in einem Computer. Da wird die Software ausgeführt und vor allem,
vertraut man auch diesen Betrieb äh eigentlich immer.
Also die CPU ist das, was ihr in Gigaherz kauft? Die Einheit für CPU ist Gigaherz, ja? Ähm, oder, oder, Anzahl davon, aber.
Stellen wir uns diese Rechenmaschine vor, die Time jetzt gerade beschrieben hat, die muss ja auch irgendetwas rechnen können, ja? Die braucht ja,
Irgendwo muss die Information ja herkommen, die sie berechnet.
Da geht's im Prinzip verschiedene Stufen auf eurem System. Ihr habt ja hier eine Festplatte drin oder eine SSD, die beide verhältnismäßig,
enorm langsam sind in dem Bereitstellen der Information, wenn man sich überlegt mit welcher,
Geschwindigkeit der Prozessor rechnet, ja? Wenn man dem also nix besonders kompliziertes zu tun gibt, kann der eigentlich kann der sehr viel schneller Daten aufnehmen als ihr von eurer Festplatte kommen,
Deswegen haben wir den Arbeitsspeicher, in dem der Prozessor,
den größeren Teil der Information, mit denen er so im Moment jongliert, verwaltet, das heißt, er holt die sich einmal von der Festplatte, langsam lädt er das Photoshop und das Bild und dann fängt er an und macht alles nur in dem Arbeitsspeicher
der oder verwaltet den größeren Teil der Information in diesem Arbeitsspeicher und bisher dann sagt Speichern und dann schreibt er das wieder auf den noch langsameren Speichern.
Und das ist vor allem so ein globaler Garten, wo der Code und die Daten, die geladen werden, da alle so drin landen, alle in einem Blick.
Genau, denn euer Computer hat ja führt ja zu jedem Zeitpunkt mehrere Programme aus,
mehrere Prozesse, vielleicht habt ihr den Eindruck, dass wie, ich habe doch jetzt gerade nur E-Mail auf, ja, aber ihr habt ja auch zum Beispiel noch,
Linux, den Linux-Körner, der da läuft oder ihr habt auch vielleicht das andere Programm, was ihr gerade weggetappt habt, äh von dem ihr gerade weggeschaltet habt, das ist ja trotzdem auch noch da. Das sind eben verschiedene Prozesse auf einem auf einem Computer,
Und dass äh der Prozessor, warum wir jetzt nicht zu sehr ins Detail gehen, wechselt zwischen diesen Prozessen,
hin und her und schenkt immer jedem dieser Prozesse dann seine volle Aufmerksamkeit,
Gleichzeitig hat er aber die Informationen, die er im Arbeitsspeicher hat,
und in seinem noch schnelleren, der der Prozessor selber kann ja auch nicht vollständig agnostisch sein, der hat auch nochmal einen Speicher, der wiederum noch schneller ist,
der sogenannte Cash. Und dieser Speicher ist so schnell, dass er so teuer wäre, dass wir uns im Vergleich dazu sehr viel langsameren Rahmen gönnen.
Um Menge zu haben und im Vergleich dazu nochmal viel langsamere Festplatte. Das heißt, wir für den Prozessor gibt es,
Verschiedene Geschwindigkeiten,
in denen er Informationen zu sich holen kann. Und wenn ich jetzt von Speicherbereichen spreche, dann meine ich die Speicherbereiche, die der Prozessor hat, die also in dem Prozessor selber sind,
Und jetzt stellen wir uns eine einfache Situation vor. Ihr führt ein Programm aus.
Unbekannter Herkunft aus?
Irgendein Programm, habt ihr runtergeladen oder warufer Computerbild-CD mit dabei, ja? Das führt ihr jetzt auf eurem Computer aus, dann wird das also so, dann rechnet das so vor sich hin. Und der Prozessor.
Führt aber gleichzeitig in eurem Betriebssystem für euch gefühlt, gleichzeitig habt ihr auch noch euren Passwortsafe, auf den ihr ja alle habt, in dem die Passwörter gespeichert sind,
Und was jetzt passiert, ist der Prozessor ordnet jedem dieser beiden Prozesse, seine Speicherbereiche zu und achtet darauf,
dass der Prozess im der Kontext A Prozess, der von der Computerbild-CD oder was, ne, der der nicht vertrauenswürdige Prozess nicht auf den Speicher des anderen zugreifen darf,
'ne fundamentale Sicherheits,
Maßnahme, die es eben äh verhindern soll, das Programm aus dem, dass das Programm im Kontext A irgendwelche Informationen aus dem anderen Programm extrahieren kann. Zum Beispiel ein,
Passwort lesen kann oder so.
Das heißt, was ihr euch merken müsst, ist ein Programm darf nicht auf den Speicher eines anderen Programmes zugreifen. Und das stellt der Prozessor sicher,
indem er jedem Programm sagt, das ist der der Speicher von Programm A, das ist der Speicher von Programm B und wenn jetzt Programm A den Speicher von Programm B lesen möchte,
dann crashe ich das, dann gibt's nämlich eine Exeption, fertig, dann gibt's äh einen Abbruch, dann stürzt es ab und nein, das darf es nicht. Ja, kriegst du den Errot zurück, gib es nicht,
Das heißt im.
Eine wie heißt das bei Windows so schön, eine Schutzklub Schutzverletzung.
Schutzverletzung oder Bluesgreen, wie bei Windows heißt das, keine Ahnung. Also ihr kriegt halt ein Windows.
Also ihr kriegt das.
Und das ist wirklich auf der auf der niedrigsten Ebene des Prozessors eine fundamentale ähm Sicherheitsmaßnahme.
So. Jetzt gehen wir einen Schritt zurück und gucken uns an, wie sind Prozessoren schneller geworden,
Prozessoren sind dadurch schneller geworden in den letzten Jahren, nicht unbedingt dadurch, dass man ihre ähm dass man ihre Gigaherz-Zahl immer weiter beschleunigt hat.
Also am Anfang schon.
Auch, ja? Äh und dass man also natürlich, man macht sich schneller, mit höherer Taktrate, das kommt in der Regel dadurch, dass man sie mit kleineren äh kleineren Abständen baut. Inzwischen hat glaube ich bei zehn Nanometer oder so angekommen. Ähm,
Aber Prozessoren sind irgendwann fundamental dadurch schneller geworden oder haben ihren den größeren Teil ihrer Geschwindigkeit dadurch gewonnen, dass sie klüger wurden.
Klüger in Anführungsstrichen.
In Anführungszeichen und zwar hat man verschiedene Methoden gefunden wie ein Prozessor in wenn er gerade nix zu tun hat,
Vielleicht schon einmal Arbeit verrichten kann, die er später unter Umständen braucht. Das heißt, der Prozessor nimmt nutzt nichts verwendete Ressourcen.
Um spekulativ schon einmal Dinge zu errechnen.
Von denen er in dem aktuellen Programm Fuß glaubt, dass er sie brauchen wird. Und,
das kann man die Horistiken, die der Prozessor dabei nutzt, kann man quasi vorhersagen. Das heißt, ich kann etwas schreiben, kann einen Programmcode schreiben und weiß, na ja.
In der Regel so ein Loop, was weiß ich, wo man irgendwas etheriert, dann weiß man na ja, der Prozessor wird davon ausgehen, dass das immer so weitergeht und er wird in seiner Freizeit spekulativ schon einmal folgende Dinge tun, die ich in diesem Loop mache,
mal sehen. Also, wir wir müssen uns merken, der Prozessor führt manchmal.
Code in einem spekulativen Kontext aus.
Der nicht dieser Hauptkontext ist, ja? Es gibt den Programmfluss und jetzt kommt der Prozessor und sagt, aha, ich habe gerade irgendwie nichts zu tun. Ich fische, ich spekuliere schon mal, was hier noch kommt und rechne das auch schon einmal aus.
Man nennt das auch Out of Order, Execution, also äh Code wird sozusagen schon weit vorher, bevor er eigentlich wirklich gebraucht wird, ausgeführt, damit er schon fertig ist, wenn man ihn braucht.
Damit der, genau, da hat er schon die Ergebnisse, ja. Also man könnte,
der der Computer weiß ja eh schon was ihr macht. So aber er sagt könnte sein, dass als nächstes das hier passiert aber ich nur warte gerade noch auf irgendwas anderes aber ich rechne das schon mal aus. Der fragt mich doch eh gleich wieder, was ist die, ne?
Jetzt stellt sich raus, wenn man in diesem Kontext, in diesem spekulativen Kontext ausgeführt wird als Code,
Und macht einen Zugriff auf Speicher, auf den man eigentlich nicht zugreifen kann.
Dann wird dieser Zugriff zunächst einmal nicht verboten. In diesen spekulativen Kontext,
kontrolliert der Prozessor also nicht in je bei jedem Speicherzugriff.
Ob das auch sein darf.
Ob das auch sein darf, aber wenn er am Ende kommt und dieses Ergebnis wirklich braucht und der größere Teil dieser spekulativen Berechnung wird weggeworfen,
Es ist nur in dem Moment, wenn er mal den Treffer hatte, dass der, dass der Nutzer eben einen sehr großen Boost hat. Aus diesem Grunde, weil der größere oder weil man davon ausgeht, dass viele dieser spekulativen Berechnungen ohnehin weggeworfen werden
Und dass die ja eh so ein bisschen ins Spekulativ sind, ins Leere laufen, werden da nicht diese strengen Kontrollen in jedem Takt gemacht,
Weil wahrscheinlich reine Spekulation, dann andauert man Blues Rinet, weil das ja spekulativ ausgeführt wird und auch nicht unbedingt,
Sinnvoll ist, was er da errechnet, aber wenn es das ist, hat er da was von. Die Kontrolle gab es quasi, in dem, was sich spekulativ ausgeführt habe, einen verbotenen Speicherzugriff,
kommt erst in dem Moment wo man wirklich auf das spekulative Ergebnis zugreift. Dann sagt der Prozessor,
Ich gucke mal kurz, nee, da war ein verbotener Speicherzugriff bei, das darf ich gar nicht benutzen.
Ich nehme diese, ich nehme dieses Ergebnis jetzt nicht entgegen, denn da ist offenbar irgendwas schiefgegangen. Das heißt, ich werfe das weg.
Nimm alles zurück, was ich äh äh ausgeführt habe.
Rechne das jetzt nochmal neu und mach das jetzt nochmal ordentlich,
Und zwar so wie es mir der normale Programmfluss diktiert, weil offenbar ist hier irgendwas schiefgegangen. Soweit, so gut, dachte man. Und sagte, naja okay, wir haben hier potenziell die Möglichkeit ähm Speicherzugriffsverletzungen zu begehen,
Aber wir gucken ja am Ende, ob wir eine begangen haben. Und wenn das der Fall war dann.
Dann rechnen wir nochmal neu.
Und das ermöglicht es dem, dir das ermöglicht, diese Angriffsklasse. Ich erkläre jetzt nur einen, ein bisschen grob da, wie gesagt,
Wir springen da viele Details. Was man in einer solchen Situation braucht. Man ist ja, man man schreibt also Code, der möglichst,
Prädestiniert ist, dass der Prozessor sagt, ach geil, das kann ich auch spekulativ ausführen, ja? Und dann weiß man, wenn ich das schaffe, dann kann ich,
In diesem Kontext auf verbotene Speicher Bereiche zugreifen, die mir eigentlich nicht gehören, dann kann ich also als Programm A den Speicher von Programm B, der ist in meiner Hand,
Ich kann ihn echt berühren. Ich brauche jetzt nur noch einen Weg wie ich das zurückgebe an mein Hauptprogramm,
Aber mein Hauptprogramm kriegt meine Ergebnisse nicht direkt zurück, weil ich habe ja eine Speicherverletzung begangen.
Du kannst dich nach Hause telefonieren, aber du kannst vielleicht an die Wand klopfen.
Du kannst vielleicht an die Wand klopfen und du brauchst, was man in diesem Fall einen Seitenkanal nennt. Du hast keinen direkten,
keine direkte Kommunikationsmöglichkeit zurück? Aber die Forscher haben sich dann gesagt, na ja, was haben wir denn, was können wir denn vielleicht an bleibenden,
Naja, bleibend äh äh oder vielleicht auch an flüchtigen Veränderungen überhaupt vornehmen, die wir in irgendeiner Form, in dem Hauptprogramm Kontext vielleicht doch wieder auslesen können oder messen können,
Und da hat sich bei hat sich ein Seitenkanal ergeben, der im Prinzip darin besteht, von dem ganz schnellen Speicher,
den der Prozessor hat, nämlich den Cash, also der im Prozessor dabei ist, der den kauft ihr nicht dazu, der ist wenige, also viel, viel, viel, viel kleiner,
Der ist im Prozess vor drin, der könnte ja nicht mit dranstecken, sondern der ist wirklich auf dem Prozessor selber mit drauf, in dem gekühlten Teil,
und der ist so schnell, dass man sehr genau einen Unterschied messen kann.
Ob die Information, die ich jetzt gerade aus dieser Speicherbank lese ähm.
Gecasht wurde oder nicht.
Gecasht wurde oder nicht. Also ich kann als Programm feststellen, hol mir mal bitte diese Information.
Auf die ich zugreifen darf.
Und ich sehe dann, ob der Prozessor oder ich gucke einfach nur auf die Stopptuhr und sage, naha, hat der sich das jetzt aus seinem, kriege ich das gerade aus dem Cash? Oder kriege ich das aus dem Rahmen? Da ist eben ein fuck, riesige Faktorenunterschied, ein Netz in der Zeit.
Sagen würde, ich gehe jetzt mal Zigaretten kaufen und bist irgendwie fünf Sekunden später wieder da, hast die Dinger in der Hand, hatzt du sie wahrscheinlich schon in deiner Tasche?
Naja oder na ja oder oder ich sage Tim, ne, gib mal Kippe und du du gehst, du bist fünf Minuten weg, dann weiß ich, okay, der ist jetzt zum Spät hier gegangen und hat äh mir Schokozigaretten gekauft.
Oder du holst eine aus der Tasche und sagst nimm doch die hier.
Genau, also man merkt, ob's schnell ist, ja total. Ich verdiene jetzt auch keine geben.
Keine. Ja, glaube ich nicht. Das.
Das glaube ich nicht. Ja. Und jetzt ähm darin,
Haben die Forscher eben einen Seitenkanal gefunden, nämlich zu sagen, aha, dann gehen wir doch einfach in unseren Speicherbereich, auf den wir zugreifen dürfen und laden da mal irgendwie in die verschiedenen Speicherbänke.
Ähm schon mal Informationen rein. Und das ist ja etwas,
was wir im Hauptprogrammkontext dann wieder feststellen können, nämlich das Hauptprogramm geht dann einfach hin und liest eine Speicherbank,
nach der anderen aus und sagt aha, Bank eins, langsam, Bank zwei, langsam. Äh Bank drei, schnell, Bank vier, langsam, Bank fünf, langsam, Bank sechs schnell. Ja, dann weiß man, aha,
In der Bank drei und in der Bank sechs wurde offenbar vorher schon mal schon mal zugegriffen, vorher schon mal was reingeladen. Und das ist die Information.
Einer der Wege, wie ich aus dem Spekulativen Kontext doch quasi Daten zurückmorsen kann. An den.
Eigentlich.
An den eigentlichen Programmkontext. Und jetzt kommt die Kombination. Ich gehe also in den spekulativen Kontext hin,
Greife auf den Speicher zu, auf den Verbotenen und sage, ach wunderbar, hier ich habe einen Beit jetzt mir genommen, nehme jetzt als Beispiel einen Beit ist acht Bit lang,
Und jetzt gehe ich einfach hin und sage, okay, äh der der erst das erste Bit von meinem Bike ist eine Null. Also lade ich die ähm erste Speicherbank nicht,
Das Zweite wird in mein,
bald ist eine Eins. Da lade ich also jetzt die zweite Speicherbank. Man hat also quasi eine Geheimsprache in Anführungszeichen. Zwischen seinem spekulativen Kontext und dem wirklichen Kontext,
die sich darin manifestiert, welche Speicherbänke man vorgeladen hat. Im Cash,
Und der Hauptkontext geht einfach hin und guckt ein, geht mit der Stoppuhr hin und guckt, wie schnell sind gerade meine Speicherbänke. Aha, schnell, langsam, schnell, langsam, schnell, langsam, das heißt meine Informationen sind so und so aus,
Und das ist diese äh dieser dieser Seitenkanal in Kombination mit, dass man um die schnelle Ausführung zu ermöglichen.
Ähm diese spekulativen äh Out of Order ähm,
Kalkulationen eingeführt hat und da gesagt hat, damit die schneller laufen können und weil die ja irgendwie sowieso wegkommen und weil die auch einfach mal falsch spekuliert sein können, ähm machen wir da nicht bei jedem Takt
sofort das Verbot des Speicherzugriffs, sondern wir lassen die erstmal wirken und gucken erst am Ende, wenn wir's wirklich nutzen. Damit spart man sich
Ne, wenn wir davon ausgehen, dass Pferden so und so viel Prozent der Out of Order Kalkulation sowieso unbesehen weggeworfen.
Und man macht bei denen allen nicht diese Speicherzuguskontrollen,
Freut man sich natürlich, weil man sagen kann, ja, wunderbar, da haben wir unglaublich viel gespart. Da kommt dann auch der Performance-Boost her, weil ich äh weil ich da eben geringere, weil ich diese Speicherzugusprüfungen die ganze Zeit nicht machen muss.
Sondern nur.
Am Ende einmal bei dem, was ich weiterverwende. Diese beiden Sachen in Kombination ergeben jetzt den Alptraum, dass ein Programm A, den Speicher von Programm B einsehen kann.
Und nicht nur von Beser, von potenziell eigentlich allem, was so auf dem.
Potenziell allen und ähm in den verschiedenen Angriffsvarianten dann auch irgendwie Curnalbereich oder nicht. Will ich alles gar nicht drauf eingehen. Wir wollten's jetzt so ein bisschen vereinfachen.
Jetzt sagt man, na ja eigentlich nicht so schlimm, weil ich will ja eh keine Viren,
auf meinen äh Computer installieren. Ich will ja eh ne, wenn ich Malware auf meinem Rechner habe, dann ähm,
Habe ich ja eh früher oder später verloren
Ja, Dia ist, dann macht's ja halt, wenn sie das Passwort nicht aus dem, aus dem Speicher ausliest, dann macht sie halt einen Keylogger oder sonstiges. Ja, stimmt,
kann man sagen, wenn man da ist es noch nicht schlimm. Jetzt sind die an, sind die Forscher aber auf den Weg gekommen, dass sie diese Eigenschaft,
sogar über Java Skript ausnutzen können. Das heißt, es
gelingt ihnen quasi irgendwie in Java Skript zu schreiben, was euer Prozessor wiederum äh spekulativ, in out of order ausführt und dadurch greifen sie dann auf euren Passwortmanager zu, morgen sich durch den durch den Cash
die Werte zurück und und verarbeiten das am Ende in ihrem Java Skript wieder und schicken das dann an ihren Server zurück. So jetzt die ich weiß gar nicht, ob die das ernsthaft mal,
demonstriert haben, aber so zumindest das potenzielle Angriffsszenario. Das heißt, eine eine Schwachstelle, die ähm.
Die dann doch,
weil ihr die ganze Zeit nicht vertrauenswürdigen Code auf eurem Computer ausführt, doch zu fürchterlichen Problemen führen könnte,
Angriffskomplexität wird hier durchaus etwas höher,
aber ähm was ich auch immer sage, ein Angriff ist immer nur solange komplex, bis ihn jemand entwickelt hat und wenn er es da, wenn er dann nämlich einmal da ist, dann wird er natürlich selbstverständlich einfacher,
Ja? Und weil man, wenn man einmal weiß, wie es funktioniert, dann sinkt quasi auch der Aufwand für den Angreifer so etwas gezielt.
Ähm auszunutzen. Besonders schlecht ist das auch für ähm diese ganzen Cloud-Anbieter,
die ja letztendlich euch virtuelle Maschinen geben
und diese virtuellen Maschinen sind auch wiederum nur eine Reihe an Prozessen auf einer Reihe von Prozessoren, wo das auch wieder passieren kann. Das heißt, wir hätten dann hier nicht nur die Schwachstelle, dass ich.
Quasi als ein Prozess,
in den Speicher von meinem Nachbarprozess schaue, auf einem Computer, sondern wir hätten das Problem, dass potentiell ich in den Speicher eines anderen Computers schaue,
das, was jemand anders für einen Computer hält, ist ja nur eine virtuelle Maschine. Und damit ist er dann auf einmal,
wirklich ein ein Sicherheitsalbtraum, der sich,
Ja, relativ einfach, beheben liest, indem man diese Out of Order Execution einfach wieder sein lässt. Dann werden unsere Prozessor, Prozessoren aber wieder so äh ja wahrscheinlich ungefähr zurück auf dem,
Auf dem Niveau Ende der Neunziger oder sowas, ne? Oder wann man damit angefangen hat mit diesen Out of Order Executition.
Ja. Also angefangen hat es glaube ich fünfundneunzig schon ähm also soweit auch die Prozessoren äh von diesem Problem betroffen.
Und das ist natürlich schon äh krass.
Was jetzt passiert ist, es werden jetzt Patches gemacht in Betriebssystem,
Das habe ich jetzt ein bisschen außen vor gelassen, besonders schlimm ist das, wenn das Ding auf den Speicher, der den Betriebssystem kerngehört zugreift, ähm aus gegebenen, also aus verständlichem Anlass, das Betriebssystem ist halt der,
die Wurzel allen.
Übelst.
Übelst und ähm jetzt werden also verschiedene Patches ausgerollt, die.
Alle, also es gibt Updates für die Prozessoren, weil die Prozessoren auch nochmal ein Micro-Code haben, der ihnen quasi äh sagt, wie sie,
zu operieren haben. Es gibt Patches auf den Betriebssystemebenen, also die Linux-Curne-Entwickler sind die ganze Zeit schlecht gelaunt, weil sie da irgendwie mit ihren irgendwelchen Patches hantieren und die erstmal die üble Folge ist, das hat,
ähm folgen für die Performance. Also jeder jeder jede Möglichkeit diesen.
Diese Angriffsklasse zu verhindern.
Hat damit zu tun, dass man irgendwie den Prozessoren, den Speed-Benefit wegnimmt, den sie durch diese Out of Order-Exekution haben.
Und das bedeutet, das geht richtig in die äh richtig in die Performance. Primär in den Bereichen,
Wo man viel zwischen Körne und äh Programm wechselt oder eben zwischen verschiedenen Kontexten. Das ist auf unterschiedlichen Prozessoren, in unterschiedlichen Ausführungsumbedingungen,
unterschiedlich der Fall, also auf es kommt wirklich darauf an, welches Programm ihr benutzt. Ja, äh, auf eurem Rechner,
wie inwiefern das betroffen ist, wenn wenn nun das Betriebssystem oder der Prozessor gegen,
Inspektor. Mehr tut.
Man muss dazu sagen.
Kann bis zu fünfundzwanzig Prozent sein oder sowas, ne? Oder vierzig Prozent.
Performance, ja, ja die nicht so durchgehend unter Umständen ist, aber das da das ist glaube ich auch die finale Rechnung noch nicht gemacht. Da muss man jetzt mal schauen.
Kommt wirklich, kommt sehr darauf an, was man tut.
Was jetzt auch nochmal, glaube ich, ganz wichtig ist, darauf hinzuweisen ist, ist jetzt halt nicht so, dass es jetzt Problemerkant Gefahr gebannt und jetzt hat man den den Backgefixern
der eigentliche Buck ist so grundlegend, der lässt sich so überhaupt gar nicht fixen. Abgesehen davon, dass halt einfach diese Generation von
Prozessor noch sehr, sehr, sehr lange äh in Betrieb sein wird, selbst wenn man jetzt morgen eine Lösung findet, wie man das Ganze ohne diese Sicherheits äh Lücke implementieren kann, was
weil meiner Kenntnis nach jetzt noch nicht unbedingt so vor der Tür steht, also bisher ist so die künftige Prozessorgeneration halt nach.
Mehrere Jahre, ne?
Nach demselben Modell geplant und und wird wahrscheinlich auch noch auf eine absehbare Zeit so weiter exekutiert werden und äh,
die Schutzmechanismen, die halt jetzt hochgefahren werden, die Patches schützen halt gegen die jetzt publizierten und bisher geborenen Angriffsszenarien. Aber es ist durchaus vorstellbar.
Das jetzt pfiffige Leute auch noch auf andere äh Angriffsszenarien
kommen, die wir jetzt so noch gar nicht diskutieren können, weil wir sie nicht kennen. Ähm die äh letzten Endes dieselbe Lücke ausnutzen, aber auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise, wo halt äh bestehende Patches
auch nicht helfen und das ist natürlich jetzt insofern eine eine wie heißt es schon eine Schwankung in der in der in der Macht, ja?
Wo man noch nicht so genau weiß, was Sache ist.
Vor allem weil es sehr wenige, also die sehr wenige Menschen gibt, die Prozessorarchitektur und die wirklich,
Befehle für Prozessoren in der Tiefe verstanden haben, dass sie ernsthaft sagen können, okay diese,
Andere Stresse funktioniert jetzt gar nicht mehr. Es geht ja hier um, ne? Es geht ja um zwei Sachen. Es gibt einmal diesen Seitenkanal und diesen Speicherzug und eigentlich muss man beides loswerden. Für den, für die Idee des Seitenkanals gab's auch schon die Vorschläge zu sagen, warum,
gibt der Prozessor,
dem Programmkontext überhaupt so genaues Timing, ja? Man könnte ja einfach man könnte diese Informationen einfach nicht mehr geben. Dass man, dass der, dass das Programm einfach nicht mehr die Möglichkeit hat, in seinem Programmkontext festzustellen,
Wahr, wie schnell kam das jetzt, ja? Äh, dass wir, dass man dem dem Programm quasi in seinem Bewusstsein die Stoppuhr wegnimmt,
Ich vermute aber, dass es für, dass es einige Anwendungen gibt im Multimedia-Bereich, die genau diese Stoppuhr sehr genau brauchen können. Ähm insofern die Folgen,
für das, was Menschen mit Prozessoren machen. Ähm.
Sind da sind da irgendwie schwer abzusehen und entsprechend auch die äh die Ideen, was man noch alles an Angriffen kombinieren könnte. So ein Prozessor hat eine ganze Menge Befehle
die er ausführt und in allen möglichen Kombinationen
irgendwie ausführen kann, insofern, wie du schon sagst, kann es sehr gut sein, dass wir da das demnächst einfach weiter Seitenkanäle kommen. Was weiß ich, dann funkt der Prozessor sichert was
Der brummt, der der schwingt ja auch mit ein paar Gigaherz, dann genutzt der halt seine Eigeninduktionsmöglichkeiten, um zu gucken
wie es war oder seinen eigenen Stromverbrauch oder also Seitenkanäle gibt es überall und Seitenkanäle sind sehr schöner Forschungsbereich in der IT-Sicherheit,
Äh und es sieht halt alles gerade nicht so gut aus. Es sieht ist gerade echt kein keine Zeit, Computer zu kaufen.
Ja und vor allem die Prozessorhersteller hatten ja auch schon vorher irgendwie eine schlechte Zeit, wir hatten ja auch auf dem Kongress glaube ich zwei Vorträge zu so einem äh vielleicht nicht ähnlichen, aber ähnlich gelagerten Fall
ähm ist ja auch Breitdrücke diskutiert worden, die ähm Management äh Engine
Man lernte auf einmal, wenn man sich nicht ohnehin schon ein bisschen mehr damit beschäftigt hat, dass halt die Prozessoren sehr viel mehr Intelligenz äh mittlerweile in sich tragen, als man das so gemeinhin
vermutet hat. Ich meine, die alte Generation von Prozessoren, die war halt sehr einfach. Das war mehr oder weniger fest verdrahtetes Zeug. Das hatte ein relativ klaren
Marschplan und auch diese Metaprogrammierung, also das, welche Instruktion kann dieser Prozessor eigentlich ausführen.
Und was genau muss er dann eigentlich tun, um sie auszuführen? Das ist ja etwas, was ja auch in dieser CPU in irgendeiner Form niedergeschrieben sein muss. Man bezeichnet das eigentlich als Microcode. Unser Micro-Code war früher relativ,
einfach aber durch die Komplexität der Anforderungen, durch die Komplexität der modernen Instruktionswelten auch, ist natürlich auch dieser ganze Micro-Co-Teil.
Nicht nur größer geworden, er ist halt auch erse
Bar und Patchbar geworden, das heißt die Möglichkeit diesen Code zu ändern, hat man allein schon deshalb eingeführt, ich glaube das war damals äh mit diesem Pensium äh Rechenback, der über den sich alle so die Bäuche gehalten haben, das halt irgendwie unter bestimmten äh
Die Vision dann einfach nicht stimmte und dann haben sich alle wunderbar lächerlich gemacht über
blöde Insel und den Pensium, der halt irgendwie äh nicht bis drei zählen kann. Ja, gut, äh, den Spott haben sie sich dann sicherlich auch verdient, aber kann ja mal vorkommen und die Reaktion war dann, na ja, dann machen wir das halt patchbar
schaffen wir halt einfach die Möglichkeit auch nachträglich solche Fehler zu stopfen. Hieres Ziel, aber damit schafft man natürlich dann wiederum
einen neuen Angriffskanal und es ist jetzt nicht sicherlich nicht sicher zu sagen, äh wo man überall draufhauen kann. Also als wir dann noch gelernt haben, dass diese Management Engine
Im Prinzip nochmal so ein eigenes Betriebssystem fährt, also tatsächlich dieses Mimiks Betriebssystem, was man einzeln bisschen die Inspiration für Linox war. Ähm,
auch zum Überraschen des äh Erfinders, der auf einmal feststellte, dass ein Lehrbetriebssystem nicht, also von Herrn Tannenbaum da aus äh Amsterdam.
Der verstellte das sozusagen sein System, was bis dahin eigentlich relativ wenig Eiboys hatte, also das ist so im Universitäten Kreisen so als
Wir haben da mal ein Betriebssystem programmiert und jetzt schauen wir uns mal an, wie das so läuft mit dem Networking und allem. Dafür war's halt mal gedacht, aber das ist jetzt quasi auf jeder Insel CPU weltweit läuft, das war ihm dann sozusagen auch neu
Sprich die Prozessoren, die überall drinstecken.
Die weit verbreitet sind, denen wir eigentlich das Heiligste anvertrauen, nämlich unsere Software, unsere Sicherheit, unsere Daten, unsere Systeme, ja,
Die Stabilität auch unserer Gesellschaft in zunehmenden Maße.
Läuft irgendwie mit einem Betriebssystem mittendrin, was sich eigentlich so noch nie einer so richtig angeguckt hat, läuft mit Prozessoren, die jetzt nachweislich,
Schwachstellen haben, die man durch relativ einfache Tricks zumindest so weit bringen kann, dass sie ihre internen Geheimnisse ausplaudern
wer weiß, was als nächstes kommt, ja? Vielleicht äh werden geheime Instruktionen gefunden, die irgendwelches Fehlverhalten aufdecken. Vielleicht ist es ja auch irgendwie möglich ähm
da diesen Mikro-Code komplett auszutauschen,
und äh was natürlich dann auch so ein Running Gag ist aus dem Bereich der Verschwörungstheorien. So, das Hemdlerinstruktionen, also die Instruktionen, die der,
Prozessor selber ausführt, die werden ja auch mal ganz gerne mit so drei und vier buchstabigen Abkürzungen gemacht,
Weißer Geier, ob die Prozessoren nicht alle auch ein NSA-Instruktionen und NSCA-Instruktionen haben, die.
Irgendwas macht. Ja, also sprich wir sehen uns jetzt quasi in so einer Zeit mit,
Mist Jour Hardware konfrontiert, also man muss sich sozusagen darüber Gedanken machen, wie man Systeme jetzt sichert,
ohne anzunehmen, dass die Hardware auf der man läuft schon mal eine sichere Basis ist. Ist sie nicht mehr.
Ja aber also was war der letzte, man sagt ja vom C vierundsechzig, das war der letzte Computer, den man noch in seiner Grenze verstehen konnte. Du hattest da äh auch immer ein sehr schönes CRE zu, glaube ich.
Ja mit Michael Stahl, das war sehr sehr nette, war das so seine Aussage, als ich fragte, warum er sich denn eigentlich mit so einem alten Ding äh beschäftigt hat. Na ja, das kann man halt noch komplett verstehen als einzelner Mensch.
Also die kommt vollständige Komplexität der CPU und des Systems ist,
erlernbar. Das ist, das ist etwas, wo man die vollständige Maschine äh verstehen kann. Ich unterstreiche das auch. Das äh damit habe ich mich ja auch damals beschäftigt und das stimmt,
das natürlich heutzutage kaum noch.
Ist nicht mehr unbedingt der Fall.
Nee, ist sehr weit von entfernt.
Ja, also sichert euch nochmal
Wir brauchen das irgendwann für den Untergrund. Sichere Rechner, die wir nachvollziehen und verstehen können. C vierundsechzig scheint eine ganz gute Basis zu sein
pack den aber nochmal in Alufolie ein, weil das nee, ja, das Ding strahlt wie Hulle und da habt ihr bestimmt auch noch zwanzig Seitenkanäle, da kann man wahrscheinlich mit der, mit einem nassen Schnürsenkel aus fünf Meter Entfernung auch noch die Passwörter ausles.
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber dass das ähm was ich daran so faszinierend finde ist, also.
Jetzt fixen die alle ihre Betriebssysteme, ja oder oder wenn irgendwelche Micro-Code-Updates gemacht, ja. Und jetzt stell, jetzt stellst du auf einmal fest, ähm.
Also insbesondere so Cloud, Hosting, nutzende Unternehmen und das muss äh muss man eigentlich sagen, ist fast jedes Unternehmen, es unterhält heute keiner mehr im Rechenzentrum.
Die haben. Also nur noch sehr wenige.
Nur noch sehr wenige tun das, die, die dein Startup ist eine äh ist eine eine Google-Diskussionsgruppe und ein und eine fette Rechnung von Amazon für die Cloud-Ressourcen, die du benutzt, ja? Tatsächlich
Und die die quengeln dann jetzt und
genau das ja.
So und das ist sehr schön, weil das nciht natürlich auch ein Nährboden für Innovation ist und die Möglichkeit auch kleinen Unternehmen gibt,
Zu sagen, ja wir bauen jetzt mal hier was und dann skalieren wir das eben hoch und äh Amazon verdient auch mit, das heißt alles sind glücklich,
Was ist das alles fürchterlich? Ich will das da jetzt nicht irgendwie so ähm,
Und jetzt kriegen die auf einmal, jetzt sagt Amazon, ja, wir haben ja hier den äh den Hypervizer a neu gestartet und ähm äh jetzt ist äh
Frohe Kunde, ihr seid jetzt gesichert gegen was weiß ich Spectown, Meldown, äh gehen sie weiter, hier gibt's nichts zu sehen. Und auf einmal sehen die die Verbrochenheit auf einmal zwanzig Prozent mehr,
Und das stellt natürlich also so aktueller Stand. Äh Amazon im Zweifelsfall eine Rechnung
Und sagt, ja wieso, die Zyklen habt ihr doch verbraucht. Was kann ich denn dafür, wenn eure Programme äh.
Sieht so schlecht optimieren lassen.
Nicht so schlecht optimieren lassen ähm und unsere Prozessoren unsicher sind. So, jetzt frage ich mich ernst, das wäre also,
Sagt Amazon jetzt, ja, nee, habt Recht, wir haben hier offenbar äh ganz schön viel äh Schrottprozessor gekauft. Machen wir mal die Preise billiger, das können wir ja nicht zumuten,
oder sagt Amazon, hör mal. Die letzten vierundachtzigtausend Paletten Xon Prozessoren äh die war irgendwie nicht so geil,
Ja, also.
Mussten wir drosseln.
So, äh dass das äh und und dann tatsächlich auch
die diskutieren ja alle nur ja Amazon-Dingens, ne? Ja, das sind auch Energiekosten, die da entstehen, wenn da, wenn mehr CPU verbraucht wird, entsteht mehr Wärme
werden unsere Cloud-Anwendungen langsamer Gott bewahren. Äh das will natürlich keiner, das heißt am Ende,
ist das eine hat das auch eine ökologische Konsequenz sowas? Weiß nicht in welchem Rahmen die sich jetzt,
am Ende abspielt, weil es eben sehr darauf ankommt, was man macht,
auf einem zwischen den Prozessoren, auf welche Maschinen und so weiter. Aber das ist äh,
das ist ein Problem von einem so großen Ausmaß, dass wir es im Zweifel einfach nicht lösen,
Ja, haben wir ja auch regelmäßig als Menschheit, ja? Dass man sagt, ah äh oh Kacke, Banken, ja nee, äh nee, die können wir nicht pleite gehen lassen. Müssen wir jetzt äh nicht lösen,
müssen wir Geld drucken oder so, ja? Ist tatsächlich so, dass dass es manchmal Probleme gibt, die sind einfach so groß mit denen äh finden wir uns dann ab,
tatsächlich. Mehr, mehr Probleme, als man glaub.
Ja, also nächsten Jahre könnten spannend werden. Ich sehe auf jeden Fall äh im offenen Bereich viel Anstrengung kommen auf uns zu.
Alle nochmal hier so zu unseren Retro-Computing-Freunden gehen und sagen, hör mal, hast du nicht noch kann ich nicht, kann ich, die wächst da, ne? Kann ich.
Ja, baue mir mal eine CPU, die irgendwie, also ich meine, es gibt ja schon seit längerem Projekte so offene CPUs, äh auf eine CPU-Eichsarchitekturen zu fahren. Ich habe jetzt gerade den Stichwort nicht im Griff. Es gibt doch da diesen Instructor äh Set, diesen offenen
äh musst nochmal nachschlagen, habe ich jetzt gerade nicht im Kopf, aber es gibt schon längere Zeit äh solche Bestrebungen, wo man sich ja bisher immer noch gesagt hat, na ja, warum soll ich denn irgendwie so ein Ding äh benutzen, so.
Jetzt wird's halt äh spannend mit Open Source Hardware et cetera,
und kann gut sein, dass wir uns irgendwie in ein paar Jahren so unsere Computer auch so mit la Carte Privatprozessoren vollballern, vielleicht ein bisschen auf Performance verzichten,
aber dafür eben anderen Sicherheitslevel haben.
Na oder wir wir vergessen's einfach wieder, ne.
Und machen einfach was anderes. Legen uns am Strand und egal, scheiß Computer.
Deine Sandburg ist auf Sand gebaut, war schon mal ein äh äh Weil-Log-Och-Netzpolitik, hätten wir hier auch nehmen können.
Nochmal einen besseren Titel finden für heute.
Ähm,
Das andere Thema, was äh um die Ohren geflogen ist und was äh in Logbuch-Netzpolitik noch äh sehr viel genauere Betrachtung verdient und auch bekommen wird, ist dieses gesamte äh Desaster um das Besondere
elektronischer Anwaltspostfach, die werden wir eine eigene Sendung widmen, die wir äh übermorgen aufnehmen,
Insofern bitte ich hier nochmal um Geduld. Das Thema wollen wir,
hier unseren CC Wurzeln entsprechend natürlich ordentlich behandeln. Da gibt's ein.
Genau, also wir haben ja schon mal drüber gesprochen, aber seitdem ist auch schon wieder eine Menge passiert, dass äh.
Foles.
Das ist äh das ist wirklich ein ein sehr unterhaltsamer äh Prozess und da wir jetzt hier schon über solche kleinen Sicherheitslücken schon so viel Zeit verlieren, wo man das jetzt hier nicht.
Zu eine Sicherheitsübung, da fängt's nämlich schon an. Da fängt es schon an. Tim, ja, kleine Vernachlässigung, das der Prozessor ist so klein,
Wer davor Angst hat, der hat sie doch nicht alle. Aber hat hast du das eigentlich gesehen? Das war oh, das war so schön. Warte mal, das äh der ähm das, was der Prozessor,
Also wenn Menschen hingehen und einen Prozessor bauen, dann nennt man diesen Prozess ähm Design.
Also der Prozessor wird. Design.
Also der Prozessor wird designt und da gab es in einer mir nicht näher bekannten Zeitung,
DZ DE Zeitung oder so was? Die Dorsten der Zeitung kommentierte dazu, seit zwei Jahrzehnten sind
In unseren Computern, Laptops und Handys Chips mit gravierenden Sicherheitslücken verbaut. Anstatt das Problem ein für alle Mal zu beheben und die Prozessoren auszutauschen,
Was natürlich ein hohen mit einem hohen Aufwand in Verbindung stünde,
Ja, der wäre relativ hoch, wenn jetzt neue Pros ist. Versuchen Firmen lediglich die Lücke mit Softwareupdates zu stopfen. Ja
denn also da gehe ich sogar noch mit, also bevor die jetzt aus allen iPhones die Prozessoren wieder auslöten. Das wäre echt ärgerlich, denn das Design der Chips müsste für die Behebung verändert werden, für Designer undenkbar
Das Aussiehen geht scheinbar vor Sicherheit.
Stattdessen sind die Daten von tausenden Millionen Menschen verhacker mit einer Leichtigkeit zu bekommen,
Was bisher über die Sicherheitslücke bekannt ist, lesen sie auf der Wirtschaftsseite. Nun.
Ähm das ist wirklich lustig.
Das ist ähm das ist lustig. Das ist lustig. Aber ich find's auch gut, dass hier einfach mal so die Maximalforderung gestellt wird. Hört Kolben in die Hand, Freunde,
neuer Prozessor rein, was eure Designer da gemacht haben. Das geht ja wohl nicht. Und einfach mal die Prozessoren von letzten zwanzig Jahren austauschen.
Da finde ich ja tatsächlich, das wäre also und dass wir dass diese, dass das Aussehen von den Chips hier vor die Sicherheit geht, das finde ich, wenn, finde ich auch wirklich bedenklich.
Das ist doch hier irgendwie Prozessor, Lucus, Mister Store.
Mein Prozessor ist aber schöner wie deiner. Als wie als wie's als als wie deine.
Allstyler. Alster als wie deiner.
Na ja, wir lachen darüber, aber das äh ja.
Damit sie uns nicht im Hals stecken bleibt.
Okay. Kommen wir zu der beliebten, bleiben wir bei der beliebten Rubrik Todious.
Genau. Fragen können, der sich schon länger damit beschäftigt. Genau.
Geschichte von Nathan Rooser, ein jungen, australischen Studenten, der irgendwie so ein bisschen zu viel Zeit hatte und äh,
auch so 'ne Fitness.
App benutzt die einige Leute benutzen in dem Fall Strafer.
Was macht ihr mit so einem GPS-Tracker, da kannste deine Touren? Fährst du Fahrrad oder rennst um Block.
Genau, deshalb vor allem ist es so eine ist halt so eine Clown. Genau, das ist halt so eine Cloud, wo dann irgendwie diese ganzen Daten von deinen Fitnessträgern irgendwie äh landen und das benutzt ja heutzutage eine ganze Menge Leute. So, diese Fitnes.
Auch gegeneinander fahren, ne? Da fährt also ich benutze das nicht, weil dann fährst du irgendwie eine Strecke und dann kommt auf einmal irgendwie einer von deinen Buddies Challenge dich,
Und fährt hier dann schneller und dann kriegst du eine Push-Notification auf die Uhr, was weiß ich. Der ist gerade schneller gefahren als du so willst den Tag ja nicht beginnen. Wenn du auf Sofa. Aber genau dafür ist diese, dafür ist diese App da.
Da sind auf jeden Fall schon eine Menge,
Albernheiten äh entwickelt worden, dieses ganze Anfeuern und was nicht alles, was er sich äh ausgedacht wird, um irgendwie Leute dazu zu bringen, da ihre überschüssigen Kilogramms abzulaufen. Also na ja,
Auf jeden Fall,
Diese Daten werden halt gesammelt und anonymisiert. Wenn ihr dann auch teilweise so auf so Karten gemappt, dann zackt man dann einfach mal, wo die Leute alle so lang laufen.
Muss dazu eine Strafe hat, wenn ich das richtig erinnere aus der Zeit, wo ich den App genutzt habe, wie gesagt, ich wehre mich überhaupt nicht dagegen, dass die Leute motiviert werden, sich mal zu bewegen. Ich habe das nur nicht gerne, wenn andere schneller sind als ich auf dem Rennrad. Also wenn man,
bei Straver sofort blocken.
Silencen. Ähm nein. Die da da geht's auch tatsächlich, dass du dann so mal eine Runde empfiehlst, ja? Und sagst hier, das ist die äh und da da nutze ich, wie gesagt, eine andere App auch sehr gerne, wo ähm,
wo man dann irgendwo ist und sagt, ach wo kann ich denn hier mal schön fahren, ne? Bis zum Beispiel sage ich mal in so,
sehr in so komischen, abgelegenen Gegenden wie Westberlin, ja? Sagst, wo kann man denn hier fahren? Und dann hat da jemand gesagt, hier die nette Feierabendrunde.
Was weiß ich, was die in Westberlin haben. Kudamm, Wasser, nein. So, dann äh,
Fährst schöne Runde durch den Grunewald oder hier mit dem Rennrad raus zum Radio Fritz oder so. Ähm.
Und das kann man sich dann da empfehlen und ruhten quasi äh auch teilen und äh so weiter. Und jetzt sind die von Strafer hingegangen und haben gesagt, oh, guck mal,
wir haben ja hier Data, ne? Und Visualisation haben wir auch.
Visualis war Aleman.
Ja, hauen wir mal rauf. Und das ist eigentlich auch gar kein Problem, weil wenn ihr jetzt so im West,
der Welt äh schaust sich so halt, wo so im Wesentlichen Excess Heiz äh gemacht wird und das fällt dann irgendwie nicht weiter auf, weil Central Park kennt ja jeder, da wird halt irgendwie viel rumgelaufen.
Problem ist, gibt jetzt auch noch so Bereiche, da sind nicht ganz so viele Leute aus der westlichen Hemisphäre, die solchen ähm
Hobbys äh anhängen und na ja auf jeden Fall unser australischer äh Student hat dann sozusagen einfach mal ein bisschen Karten gesurft, weil die werden ja so global ausgelegt, solche Heatmaps, wo man halt sehen kann, wo sind viele Leute mit ihrem Fitnesskram aktiv.
Wo laufen eigentlich die Afghanen.
Ja, stellt sich, er stellt sich raus, die Afghanen laufen eigentlich gar nicht, aber die Armis laufen, aber durch Afghanistan und sind da auch so ziemlich die einzigen mit einem Fitnesstracker. Was dann dazu führt,
Alle militärischen Basen und sonstige Truppenstandorte in Afghanistan. Wunderbar auf dieser Heatmap bis auf den kleinsten
Laufweg äh sich sozusagen abzeichnen und ansonsten eigentlich gar nichts, weil der Rest ist dann einfach äh ja.
Man könnte sagen ähm der Talip hat offenbar auch mein Buch über Obsek gelesen.
Ja ja, also äh kurz gesagt, wenn man halt auf diese Karten drauf schaut, zeichnen sich halt einfach diese ganzen Sachen ab so und irgendwie ist offenbar auch das amerikanische Militär jetzt da komplett äh
Überrascht gewesen, wo sie auch so ein bisschen fragen muss.
Ich habe aber auch andere, ich habe dieses Ding jetzt, also,
nicht so sehr verfolgt, aber ich habe auch irgendwie gesehen, dass einige äh in den Screenshots meinten, ausmachen zu können, dass offenbar das, dass dieses,
Tracking sich quasi diese Headmap um einen dunklen Kreis war.
Wo sie sich zu der Spekulation hingeleitet fühlten, dass auf dieser Basis offenbar ein GPS-Gemmer genutzt wurde,
dass sie also quasi wie gesagt, das ist jetzt ankonform, wo die quasi sagten, offenbar hat man hier so viel Sorge um den.
Um die Geheimhaltung der Basis, dass man das GPS-Signal sogar stört, damit keine Geräte, die sich da befinden über GPS überhaupt herausfinden können, wo sie sind.
Und so wurde sich eben erklärt, dass dann eben die,
die besten unter den Soldaten so weit laufen, dass sie irgendwann aus dem Bereich des GPS-Gämmers raus sind. Ähm,
und dann irgendwie äh dass da irgendwie entsteht, keine Ahnung, kann er auch sein, dass die äh vielleicht irgendwie in irgendeiner Amazon-Cloud den Fleck gesetzt haben, diese GPS-Daten gibt's nicht oder so. Aber,
ja natürlich wenn du deine Daten äh wenn du irgendwie solche Sachen trackst oder irgendwie äh hochlädst, dann ist eben auch eine,
in diesem Fall,
Pseudonyme oder anonyme äh Veröffentlichung dieser Werte, wie es ja da eben ist, ist ja eine Headmap, da steht ja nicht dran, Sargent, hasse nicht gesehen, ist hier laufen gegangen, sondern es steht einfach nur hier,
Laufen viele, das ist eine gute Laufroute. Wenn du eben dann irgendwo mitten in der Wüste,
in Ländern, wo eigentlich sonst niemand diese App nutzt, sodass da eben die,
Schluss nahe stand. Aber ich versteh, es ist jetzt irgendwie auch kein, also ich kann da jetzt auch mich nicht großartig echaufieren.
Über nein, also ja gut. Strahl, also strafer, trifft keine Schuld. Jetzt hatten im Zweifelsfall den näheren AGBs stehen, dass sie die Routen äh anonym veröffentlichen, das haben sie auch gemacht.
Nee, ich meine die Story, die sich hier quasi erzählt, ist halt dieses äh man sollte sich schon darüber Gedanken machen, wo man denn sozusagen seine Daten,
hingibt und das irgendwie Daten natürlich auch immer so ein bisschen Doules mäßig sind und Soldaten sollten sich sozusagen allein im Interesse ihrer eigenen Sicherheit hier vielleicht schon mal Gedanken machen, was sie aber jetzt so nicht unbedingt getan haben,
Oder man könnte auch argumentieren, dass es äh auch sehr in der Pflicht stehen sollte, solche Unternehmen irgendwie darauf hinzuweisen, wenn sie natürlich auch
nicht unbedingt ein Interesse daran haben, dass ihre Kunden jetzt so besonders datensparsam unterwegs sind und der besondere Sportlerin ja auch darin liegt, möglichst viel Daten zu teilen. Also es ist ein ist ein Widerspruch, aber es äh auch immer wieder lustig, was hast du für
Bögen schlägt. Also, ich meine, die haben jetzt so ein richtiges Problem, weil bei Strafer liegen halt einfach mal so ordentliche Verzeichnisse aller,
Truppenstandorte einfach rum und sie leuchten so richtig schön aus dem Dunkel heraus.
Aber das Gute ist zum Glück können sie ja vielleicht bei Strafa sehen, wenn die anderen auf dem Weg dahin sind. Hey, sehe jetzt, wie ich zu dieser Passe. Ähm wie stellen wir da gerade vor, du kennst ja äh in Großunternehmen spielt ja immer die eine Rolle,
Vielleicht gibt's ja dann demnächst irgendwie so Probleme mit der BYO, FT, Bring your one Fitnesstracker,
nicht mehr, ne? Kriegst einen Firmenfitnesstracker.
Wenn überhaupt.
Funktioniert zwar nicht, aber ist sicher. Wie das in den Unternehmen so sehr häufig der Fall ist. Na ja. Also wir.
Aber jetzt irgendwie die Opsec, also die Obsec von US Amerikanern in in Afghanistan war jetzt nie mein primär äh Interessengebiet.
Nö, wir müssen jetzt noch eingebaut, da wir immer noch was Lustiges.
Genau, ich habe noch was lustiges. Nee, ich habe, ich, ich habe eine Buchempfehlung,
Tatsächlich eine einfach mal eine Buchempfehlung. Muss man einfach mal machen. Und zwar äh von Tim Bu mal wieder. Tim Wu,
von dem wir hier auch schon öfter das Buch referenziert haben The Master Switch, was eigentlich so das das Werk zu,
Netzneutralität ist im weitesten Sinne, wo er mit der Netzneutralität im Prinzip die in den Kontext hängt von entstehenden,
Monopolen im Prinzip die den der Markt entwickelt sich immer zum Monopol. Du hast die schöne freie, die schöne freie äh Konkurrenz unter den
neuen in dem neuen Bereich unter den neuen Unternehmen und dann entwickelt es sich automatisch zu einigen wenigen, die dann eben nicht mehr,
freien fairen Markt haben wollen, das ist ja das zugrunde liegende Thema der Netzneutralität, dass sich dann die verbliebenen großen Player gerne äh.
Den der äh quasi so breit machen, dass sie eine Eintrittsbarriere zu dem Markt,
aufbauen, damit ihnen die Innovation der kleinen anderen nicht mehr so schnell ins Kreuz treten kann,
Also da schon ein groß, großes Buch geschrieben und das Tolle an den Büchern von Tim Woo ist, dass der so,
großartige Vergleiche findet so so toll erklärt und dann eben auch so historisch an die Sache rangeht. Und in diesem Buch Attention Merchands, dieses neue Buch, was ich jetzt auch empfehlen möchte
W-Atention Merchands gibt's noch nicht auf Deutsch. Ähm.
Die Epic Struggle Toget Inside Ourheads.
Großartig, ne? Also der die man könnte ja sagen, die Aufmerksamkeitsvermarkter könnte man das so nennen,
Äh indem er sich mit dem Geschäftsmodell auseinandersetzt, Aufmerksamkeit zu haben.
Und diese Aufmerksamkeit dann zu Geld zu machen. Im im einfachsten Sinne, ja? Äh also.
Der fängt da an großartig bei den ersten Zeitungen. Die ersten Zeitungen.
In den USA kosteten Geld, wurde also wurde eine Zeitung geschrieben und dann konnte man die kaufen, dann stand da was drin, konnte man am nächsten Tag eine neue kauf,
Dann ist irgendjemand jemand hingekommen und hat gesagt, passt auf, Freunde, ich mache eine Zeitung, die gibt es kostenlos.
Die gibt's kostenlos. Kannste nehmen. Und,
Die hatte natürlich innerhalb kürzester Zeit eine stärkere Auflage, als die Zeitungen, die Geld gekostet haben. Und dann hat er diese Wirkmacht seiner Shootings da Zeitung, die jetzt auf einmal so ein Erfolg,
prognostiziert. Erfolg war, hat er dann monetarisiert durch Werbung, ne? Und äh sagt dann also das war quasi die
so in dieser Vergangenheit beginnt er. Und zeigt dann, wie sie, welchen Einfluss das auf Zeitungen hatte,
dass die Zeitungen natürlich dann in Konkurrenz standen und dass äh dass dieses Geschäftsmodell natürlich sofort von allen adaptiert wurde oder ein Mischformen gegangen ist und dass dann gleichzeitig diese Zeitung natürlich konkurriert haben, um,
wie viel, wie viel verkaufe ich? Denn daran ist mein Einkommen gebunden an meinen Erfolg. Wie bekomme ich Aufmerksamkeit? Und dass dann eine lange Forschung
Das nimmt er eben über viele hundert Seiten auseinander. Äh die psychologische Forschung einsetzte in den verschiedenen Medienbereichen. Wie kriegen wir Aufmerksamkeit
Wie kriegen wir die am besten? Und äh wie dann eben die Werbeindustrie.
Diejenigen, die Werbung treiben, was die, also die großen Unternehmen, was die,
im Prinzip für Sachen finanziert haben, ja? Also Rundfunk, gleiches Thema, ursprünglich äh sehr staatlich, dann fingen irgendwann oder sehr,
Einfach gehalten, eigentlich Rundfunk fing mit der Idee an, dass man Rundfunk braucht, damit man Radios verkaufen kann. Ja ähnlich wie Applemann, iTunes angefangen hat, damit sie.
IPods verkaufen können. Ähm und dann fing das an, dass Sendungen gesponsert wurden,
dass dann also die Sendung heute präsentiert von Hasse nicht gesehen. Und dann ging's weiter, bis wir jetzt irgendwann das, was heute, also ich meine, wenn man hier Privatradio hört, wird man ja wahnsinnig, ne, mit denen. Ähm und das, das zeichnet er so nach, wie, wie da die Kämpfe,
waren, was da die,
Möglichkeiten waren, welche Geschäftsmodelle auch gefloppt sind und so. Und immer unter diesem, unter diesem äh unter diesem Blickwinkel. Und dann kommt er natürlich irgendwie zum Fernsehen. Das kennt da äh gab's auch mal, war auch mal eine Zeit lang. Dann Internet,
dann wie sich in wie sich im Internet,
In diesem wieder einmal Level Plank field, wo nämlich eigentlich die Idee der Werbung immer verpönt war bei allen, die das Internet gebaut haben, bei allen, die großen,
Dinge gestartet haben, äh Google zum Beispiel, hat einfach am Anfang einfach nur eine geile Suchmaschine gebaut. Die hatten,
Also äh hier Larry Page und Sergi Brinn hat nicht irgendwie die Idee zu sagen, ey geil und dann klastern wir da Werbung drauf,
ähm sondern die haben sich dann am Ende für dieses Modell entschieden mit den AdWords und waren da sehr vorsichtig gegen und so weiter und dann kam irgendwann dieser dieser ganze Big Data Bereich dazu und dann kam,
natürlich, aber die der Blick darauf, dass.
Aufmerksamkeit auf sich zu ziehen eben ein Geschäftsmodell ist. Und zwar in sich eines ist.
Das dann irgendwie mit Facebook die sagt, na ja, dann führen wir diesem Aufmerksamkeitsmodell. Wo gucken die Leute hin, okay, die Leute gucken Nachrichten, die Leute suchen was bei Google, die Leute ähm,
gucken Fernsehen und so weiter. Was gibt es noch? Was Menschen überhaupt machen miteinander,
wo sie also Aufmerksamkeit hintun, wo wir sie abgreifen können. Bei ihrer sozialen Interaktion, wir machen ein soziales Netzwerk und
und ballern sie damit Werbung zu, ja? Also dieses Buch ist eigentlich die ganze Zeit äh wir sind wir laufen als Menschen rum, interessieren uns für irgendwas und dann kommen andere und bauen irgendwas, was,
was uns vielleicht noch mehr interessiert, nur um die Aufmerksamkeit, die wir darauf richten, wieder irgendwo anders hinzuverkaufen. Und pervertiert wird das Ganze dann. Im Prinzip.
Also diese gesamte Idee des Internets, wo also dann irgendwann merken, okay, es gibt viral,
Viral ist eigentlich das, was die Königsdisziplin der des Aufmerksamkeitsstehens, weil da musst du gar nicht mehr zum Kunden hin, sondern dein infizierter Kunde geht hin und trägt das weiter und sagt, guck mal hier, musst du gucken
ja? Das ist das, was eigentlich dann äh Buzzfeed,
zum erklärten Geschäftsmodell gemacht hat, zu sagen wir wollen, dass die Leute uns klicken um zu klicken,
und uns ist völlig egal, was das ist,
Wir wählen unsere Inhalte, wir machen es zu unserem Geschäftsmodell, deswegen heißt die Firma ja auch Buzzfeed, also es gibt diesen diesen Feed, diesen Strom von von Information, der reinkommt und der diesen Bass äh erzeugt, ja? Und das erklärte Geschäftsmodell dieser Firma ist,
Leute sollen uns anklicken. Ja, die sind jetzt nicht mehr so wie sagen wir jetzt eine eine Nachrichtenseite, die sagt, wir möchten Journalismus betreiben,
Wir möchten was weiß ich, das Sturmgeschützt der Demokratie sein oder was weiß ich.
Wobei sich der Bass fehlt in den USA eigentlich ganz äh lobend äh errappelt. Mhm.
Gleich zu kommen, komme ich gleich zu. Äh wir ähm,
Wir haben also gesagt, wir haben noch nicht mal eine Haltung, wir haben noch nicht mal irgendeinen Anstand, wir haben noch nicht mal eine Position. Äh wir machen einfach nur Schrott und Spam mit viralem Charakter und haben das tatsächlich innerhalb kürzester Zeit,
Ähm optimiert und auch hinbekommen.
Also die haben im Prinzip die Idee des Viralen einfach nur ja pervertiert.
Und natürlich auch den größten Teil der Zeit mit entsprechender Qualität gearbeitet. Sieht man, also ich meine Buzzfeed, ich bitte dich, ja? Haben dann aber natürlich irgendwann gesehen, oh scheiße, unser äh unser Ruf leidet und haben dann in den USA ähm auch,
begonnen. Ähm,
Qualitätsinhalte zu machen. Letztendlich aber eigentlich nur diese Qualitätsinhalte erfüllen natürlich den den Zweck, den Namen wiederum zu bereinigen, ja? Äh und
quasi mehr dafür zu sorgen, dass dann eben auch ein CNN sagen muss, hier auf Buzzfeed News äh stand äh was hatten die veröffentlicht hier das Pinkel,
Ding da, ne? Ja. Der ist Pipitär.
Also nicht das Tape, aber die.
Christopher Steel oder wie der Typ heißt.
Dass Dossier, das Dossier. Genau, das ist so.
Ja genau, das ist das ist das. Genau, das ist so, da weiß man dann auch, warum landet das bei denen, ja? Bei den Leuten, die bei denen einfach der Klick,
alles ist. Der, das ist halt einfach deren Geschäftsmodell und sorry.
Das Tier war wohl bei allen, aber.
Genau, es gab nur einen, der so niedrig war, dass er gesagt hat, geil, das klickt sich doch wie nichts Gutes. Das hauen wir raus, ist uns fick egal. Ich mein, ich freue mich, dass ihr's gemacht haben,
Aber man muss einfach mal äh feststellen, also die Amerikaner, dass das Buzzfeed einfach ja, das ist halt,
Ohne alles. Das ist einfach der reine, die reine pervertierte äh Medienwelt. Ähm,
und ähm da muss man eben da habe ich irgendwie auch während ich dieses Buch darüber gelesen habe, habe ich mir so gedacht, eigentlich habe ich doch dann vor so einem Bildjournalisten oder wie nennt man die bei der Bild Reporter? Sind die, nein, sind das,
Bildreporter schreiben, die glaube ich, ne.
Glaube auch. Ich lese das ja nicht. Von daher kann ich dir das nicht.
Das finde ich ja super, kann man ja nicht lesen,
gibt ja ein AdBlocker Blocker und wenn man den Außerbetrieb setzt, wir wollen verklagt, also ist doch spitze, finde ich gut. Ähm waren fetter Warnhinweis vor Sichtbild, ja, finde ich finde ich gut. Ähm,
Da habe ich doch eigentlich vor so einem Bild äh Reporter ähm eigentlich mehr Respek,
Weil der das wenigstens noch macht, um die Leute aufzuhetzen gegen irgendwas. Der hat wenigstens mal irgendein Ziel oder irgendein Ideal und dieses dieses Buzzfeed ist einfach nur, ja, die, die,
Die Perversion irgendwie die Leute
dahin zu bringen, irgendwas anzuklicken, damit das Ding mehr Geld druckt. So, geht aber noch weiter, dummerweise leider, leider, leider waren die ja mit ihrer damit so erfolgreich, weil sie ganz einfach simple, psychologische Mechanismen äh
ausnutzen und zwar sieben psychologische Mechanismen wie Baszfit dich verarscht beim siebten wirst du klicken,
dieser Style, dummerweise haben sie damit jetzt auch,
Letztendlich jedes andere Medienhaus infiziert, ja? Die Formulierung äh klickt sich das Thema, klickt sich der Artikel, ist drin,
bei äh deutschen äh Online-Redaktionen. Bei äh ist in unserer Medienwelt drin und ähm man sieht das ja auch leider, leider, leider,
bei bei Spiegel Online sogar, dass die jetzt inzwischen diese Scam-Werbung da unten drin haben, ne? Die irgendwie.
Aussieht wie ein Artik.
Aussieht wie 'n Artikel mit dieser App lernst du sieben Sprachen in fünf Sekunden und wo du denkst, meine Güte und das ist ach großartig auch in diesem Buch drin, die Schlangenölstory.
Snakeall
Snakeall, also diese ganze quasi betrügerische Medizin, irgendwelche Elixiere und so weiter. Das hat äh über ein Jahrzehnt in den USA den Werbemarkt getrieben
Äh oder auch AOLs äh redet auch über AOL-CDs und so alles. Groß, also ist ganz tolles Buch, wunderbar geschrieben,
und lässt ein sehr über dieses Thema nachdenken, welch wem widme ich überhaupt meine Aufmerksamkeit,
was, wo gucke ich hin? Was mache ich mit meinem Kopf?
Und das finde ich hat mich sehr zum Nachdenken gebracht. Äh wer die Twitterer unter euch wissen ja vielleicht auch, dass ich in dem äh in den letzten Monat mich auch von diesem Twitter halt mal ferngehalten habe und auch nur sagen kann,
ein bisschen,
Aufmerksamkeit darauf zu richten, wohin man seine Aufmerksamkeit überhaupt richtet. Ist äh eine spannende Sache. Und ähm.
Das Buch kann ich wirklich bin ich total begeistert, habe ich jetzt aber glaube ich auch
ausführlich zum Ausdruck gebracht. Tim Ruh schreibt in diesen diesen Big Data Kram lässt der größtenteils außen vor und ich würde mal vorsichtig schätzen es wird dann wahrscheinlich sein nächstes Buch werden. Also das bietet sich einfach an, dass er als nächstes mal darüber schreibt. Also dicke Leseempfehlung,
Tim Wu über ja letztendlich das, was Werbung ist. Und was Werbung funktioniert, ist da nicht ganz so kritisch wie ich,
Sagt er, natürlich man hat uns, wir hätten den ganzen Mist im Zweifelsfall nicht gehabt, wenn es nicht eine Zigarettenindustrie gegeben hätte und eine und eine Barble-App, die den ganzen Mist dann irgendwie finanziert und Schlangenöl,
wir alle gekauft haben. Also am Ende finanzieren wir die schöne, die schöne Medienwelt, dadurch dass wir Schlangenöl kaufen, auch schön.
Genau und äh besonders gute Preise für die neusten Schlangenölprodukte am Ende dieser Sendung.
Ich kaufe nur Schlangenöl von Gasperski. Ja.
Von der Einhornstandarte.
Wir danken ähm unseren Sponsoren, nein. Vodafone danken wir.
Für einen Beitrag.
Für einen Beitrag. Den nächsten Beitrag wird wird präsentiert von Vodafone und zwar.
Genau.
So, Vodafone.
Weil die wollten jetzt auch mal was mit mit äh Desutalität machen.
Wir haben es ja schon in den verschiedenen Ländern gesehen und Thomas hat ja auch,
Thomas ist ja nun mal einfach der Experte für Netzneutralität und der ist nicht der Logbuch Netzpolitik, Experte, für Netzneutralität, sondern ist, glaube ich, inzwischen einfach mal so der, ja, Deutsch, Mindestdeutschland, wenn nicht Europaexperte,
für ein äh mindestens deutschsprachig Entschuldigung.
Mindestens deutschsprachig, wenn nicht europaweite Experte für Netzneutralität. Vodafone hat sich entschieden, ja wir machen jetzt einfach mal genau das.
Was die anderen auch machen.
Was alle? Na ja, was alle immer wovor alle immer gewarnt haben, nämlich wir geben Gigapässe, ja? In verschiedenen äh Kategorien zu. Das heißt, man wir machen genau das, wo,
was eigentlich die Netzneutralität Verfechter, wovor die immer gewarnt haben, nämlich dass wir sagen, hier,
kannst du in Chatpass buchen, dann kriegst du so und so viel äh WhatsApp für Oma. Hier kannst du eine Musikpass oder einen Videopass oder einen Social Pass buchen und jeder einzelne äh äh jedem einzelnen dieser Pässe sind,
einzelne Anbieter drin, die du dann kostenlos hast,
Wenn du wenn die Anbieter, mit denen wir nicht zusammenarbeiten, die kosten aber dann halt extra äh in deinem, der kostet die kosten dich dein Datenvolumen. Das Datenvolumen wissen wir ist in Deutschland schweineteuer und in diesen Pässen,
bilden sie also die Kartelle mit den Anbietern und äh.
Zwingen so die Nutzer in eine eingeschränkte Internetnutzung. Und dazu hat ähm,
der CCC eine Stellungnahme an die Bundesnetzagentur äh formuliert dazu hat die der Verbraucherzentrale. Bundesverband eine äh Stellungnahme an die Bundesnetzagentur formuliert und bitten,
um eine,
Ein Verbot, dieser äh Zero-Rating-Angebote genauso wie wir das bei äh Stream on der deutschen Telekom ebenfalls getan haben, weil wir eben da uns wünschen, dass das Internet als,
Internet erhalten bleibt.
Und wenn ihr ohnehin in der Lage seid uns freies Datenvolumen für äh für Video und Audio zu geben, dann seid doch bitte so lieb und gebt uns einfach,
Datenvolumen, wie wir es immer hatten, ohne dass ihr äh einschränkt und sagt, pass auf, ihr kriegt voll freies Datenvolumen, aber nur,
Für das, dass das und das und wenn ihr irgendwas anderes nutzt, mit dem ihr nicht zusammenarbeiten, dann nicht. Es gibt keinen wirtschaftlichen, wirtschaftlich für uns als Verbraucher nachvollziehbaren Grund, dass ihr das so tut. Der einzige Grund für euch, das zu tun, ist,
Kartelle zu bilden mit den Anbietern, um so das freie Internet zu bekämpfen und deswegen ist das schlecht,
Und deswegen möchten wir das nicht. Bitte.
Sonst fängt das Wasserwerk noch an, irgendwie einem das Wasser unterschiedlich abzurechnen, je nachdem, ob man's trinkt oder zum Kochen verwendet oder zum Klo spülen. Und äh.
Das geht auch nicht. Aber wieso Tim, das ist, dann ist doch Klo spielen, spülen viel billiger als Trinkwasser. Da kannst du doch nichts gegen haben.
Das wäre doch verrückt Tim, dass du für einmal Klo spielen genau so viel zahlst, wie für was ist in Spülkasten drin? Er ist bestimmt genormt, fünf Liter, fünf Liter trinken, überlege mal Tim.
Ja ist eigentlich eigentlich ganz cool. Dann kriege ich sozusagen richtig schön viel Spülmaterial, weil ich mir die ganze Scheiße auch anschaue, ähm so viel Ka.
Es wäre, es wäre, es wäre doch auch Unsinn,
Wenn das Trinkwasser in der gleichen Geschwindigkeit für das Klo spül Wasser kommen muss, da ist doch ganz klar. So und von uns, lieber Tim, kriegst du eine Klospülflatwate. Du darfst das nur nicht trinken.
So kleines Scheißerchen.
Shit on, die neue Flatrate von ihrem Wasserwerk.
Oh man.
Man merkt, wir sind schon wieder über die Stunde hinaus.
Wir wurden von der Heiseredaktion äh nee von der CT-Redaktion ähm empfohlen als Podcast und äh da wurde dann auch drin formuliert, äh dass wir regelmäßig die Neuts, die selbstgesteckte neunzig Minuten Marke reisen würden.
Ernsthaft? Also uralt. Die Marke.
Die neunzig Minuten Marke, ja, also.
Wo wohnen wir denn da empfohlen.
Jo, in der CT zweitausendacht Ausgabe vier. Steht das und ist auch äh.
Was Buntes für die Ohren. Ja. Ein Kissenbuntes.
Ja, ein Kessel buntes Bett Linus und Tim. So äh machen wir weiter Tim, wir haben die neunzig Minuten, die selbstgesetzte neunzig Minuten Marke soeben gerissen. Äh deswegen müssen wir uns jetzt beeilen.
Und kommen zu den.
Oder mich schon wieder Urgestein.
Ja Tim, irgendwann ist dann halt Urgestein.
Ja, ja, ich weiß.
Podcast Urgestein und der CCC-Sprecher.
Immerhin nennen sie uns noch vor ihrem eigenen Podcast, das finde ich das schon mal ganz okay. Und unten sind das schon wieder irgendwelche Leute, ist ja überall, ne?
CC, was sie alle überall suchen die Leute nach den Illuminaten und der CC ist genüsslich einfach überall drin. Hat überall das Chaos im Feuer.
Mein Freund. Ähm so.
Ethodisch inkorrekt, was ist das denn.
Methodische Incorrect haben jetzt letztlich irgendwann mal hinbekommen, ihre zweihundert dazu? Nee, einhundert, einhundert zu veröffentlichen, wo wir ja zu Gast waren.
Ja, haben sie uns rausgeschnitten.
Weiß ich nicht, habe ich noch nicht geguckt. Ich war ja da. Aber äh genau, wir wollen, haben wir die äh methodisch Inkorrekt einhundert, da haben Tim und ich gesungen.
Das stimmt, aber nicht nur wir allein.
Ja, wir haben uns alleine nicht getraut, kann man, aber.
Doch das würde ich schon machen. Aber wir haben, wir haben.
Ich bitte dich, du hast dich, du hast dich wirklich sehr angestellt, was das Singen angeht.
Was? Das ist überhaupt nicht wahr.
Oh, du wolltest nicht alleine singen, sonst hättest doch machen können. Methodisch inkorrekt zweihundert.
Tim macht ein Solo.
Schnickschna.
Okay, komm, wir müssen mal hier jetzt von dem äh von den Scherzen wegkommen. Ähm.
Warst jetzt schon.
Verfassungsbeschwerde gegen das BND-Gesetz. Es gibt ja N-Verfassungsbeschwerden gegen das äh BND-Gesetz.
Und jetzt gibt's eine weitere. Ähm und zwar.
Von den Journalisten, ähm die Journalistenorganisationen deutscher Journalistenverband, deutsche Journalisten, Union,
Netzwerk Ost oder N Ost und äh Netzwerkrecherche und Reporter ohne Grenzen,
haben die Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte zur Koordination um die Koordination gebeten,
das ist jetzt nicht überraschend. Ich glaub die GFS sitzt oder saß zumindest bei Reporter ohne Grenzen mit im Büro. Ähm insofern ist das da naheliegend und klagen,
gegen die BND Gesetznovelle. Und zwar spezifisch. Die Begründung will ich jetzt mal hier zum Besten geben,
Wir wissen, ja, es gibt ja keine äh anlasslose Massenüberwachung. Das hat uns ja der ähm wie hieß die Witzfigurnummer.
Von den ganzen Witzfiguren meinst du denn jetzt? Ach so, der.
Der jetzt bei der Bar des Puffalla. Das hat uns ja Puffalla damals erklärt, ne?
Ja. Das ist auch alles vorbei ist.
Da es die nicht gibt musste das, was man gemacht hatte, noch schnell legalisiert werden, damit das wenigstens in Zukunft nicht verboten ist, dass weil die Lehre aus dem NSR-Untersuchungsausschuss, der gezeigt hat, dass es anlasslose Massenüberwachung gab.
Und daher gab's dann eben die ähm die BND-Gesetznovelle, die dann sagt, ja, wir wollen.
Äh unter anderem die ähm Ausland, Ausland Fernmeldeaufklärung hier stärken. Und das heißt, der BND darf.
Gemäß dieser Novelle. Im Ausland gezielt mitschneiden und auswerten?
Und zwar ohne, dass es irgendeinen Verdacht gibt und ohne, dass es irgendeine richterliche Genehmigung dafür gibt, sondern der darf das einfach. Und zwar.
Nur dann, wenn er dies zum zu dem Zweck tut, Erkenntnisse zu erlangen, die von außen,
Oder sicherheitspolitischer Bedeutung für die Bundesrepublik Deutschland sind. Es kann auch sein, dass Stadttemperatur ein Hund ist. Ähm sind jetzt meine Notizen. Von außen und sicherheitspolitischer Bedeutungen. Und das ist natürlich immer gegeben.
Sein, das was spannendes bei rausko.
Wir haben das Ausland überwacht, wieso? Ja, das könnte doch von außen politischer Bedeutung sein. Ach so, ja, nee, dann bitte schön weitermachen. Ja, so.
Klar, kann das sein? Ja.
Klar. Kann doch sein. Entschuldigung. Entschuldigung, dass das Ausland für uns außenpolitisch relevant ist?
So mal was Neu.
So, dann äh so, dass das mit anderen Worten, sie dürfen's einfach.
Ist jetzt erlaubt.
Ähm da sagt er, geht jetzt die äh geht jetzt gehen die Journalisten hin äh mit Hilfe der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte, in der sich ja die,
die die ja quasi die juristische, die sich da als juristischer Dienstleister ja quasi sieht. Ich hoffe, das verzeiht man mir diese, diesen Begriff zu sagen. Wir machen hier strategische Litigation.
Das heißt, wir suchen uns potenziell in ihren Grundrechten, Verletzte, Personen,
um gute Fälle zu haben, die sich eignen, um hier dieses Gesetz zurückzutreiben.
Und auf eine äh äh um um auf eine Weitanpassung des Gesetzes oder sogar auf seine vollständige ähm äh Grundgesetzwidrigkeit quasi hinzuwirken.
Und sie sagen, hier werden äh dass die einzige Personengruppe, die dieses Gesetz ausschließt, ist, es darf nicht gezielt zur Überwachung von deutschen oder EU-Institutionen eingesetzt werden. Da da ist also eine Grenze für den BND,
in seinem sonstigen Freibrief zur Auslandausland. Fernwählerüberwachung ähm und es wird aber sonst keine Personengruppe ausgeschlossen. Zum Beispiel keine Journalisten,
Und jetzt seien die Journalisten, ja, sorry, das ist eine enorme Gefahr für unsere ähm,
Für unsere Tätigkeit, denn wir müssen ja auch, wenn wir mit Quellen im Ausland kommunizieren.
Sicher gehen, dass wir den Quellenschutz gewährleisten,
Und dieser Quellenschutz muss ja auch vor dem Bundesnachrichtendienst gelten, weil unter Umständen sagt der Bundesnachrichtendienst, ja dieses Gespräch ist für uns vor einer außenpolitischen Interesse,
Und wir haben ja ohnehin hier unseren freudigen Ringringtausch mit Amerikanern, mit äh mit Hasse nicht gesehen, allen, die wir irgendwie für für die Achse des Guten halten so ungefähr,
Und dann könnten sagen natürlich die Journalisten zu Recht in meinen Augen. Der will unsere Arbeit nicht mehr machen, dann können wir nämlich keinen Quellenschutz mehr gewährleisten, weil.
Unter Umständen, dass ja,
auch eure Außen- und Sicherheitspolitischen Interessen berührt, was wir mit ausländischen Quellen besprechen,
ähm die die Deutschen Interessen.
Sind natürlich nicht auf den auf den deutschen Journalismus beschränkt. Also der deutsche Journalismus bricht ja auch aus über Ausland und äh insofern ganz klar.
Geht das für die nicht,
Die können dann eben nicht mehr mit einem mit einer Quelle im Ausland sprechen. Wenn sie nicht wissen, dass der BND, dass das für den BND gesetzlich of Limits ist,
Und wenn man, wenn man den, wenn sie dann einer ausländischen Quelle sagen müssen, ja du kann sehr gut sein, dass der BND uns jetzt hier äh ähm,
überwacht oder euch untereinander überwacht, dann geht das eben nicht, ja? Da haben sie sich sieben ausländische Journalisten und Menschenrechner geschnappt und haben jetzt eine verfassungsbefährt Beschwerde äh geschrieben und sagen, wo
Geheimdienste mithören, kann es eben keine Pressefreiheit geben. Äh bedroht Journalist und ihre Quellen gleichermaßen und das deutsche BND-Gesetz trägt dazu bei,
und äh diese Verfassungsbeschwerde wurde jetzt eingereicht.
Formuliert, ja? Und jetzt werden wir sehen, jetzt ist das natürlich immer so bei diesen ganzen äh Gerichtssachen, dass ähm.
Zieht sich natürlich hin. Das ist jetzt äh,
Das wird jetzt Zeit dauern. Insofern ist das ja auch keine große News. Da ist jetzt eben was formuliert worden, da haben sich äh Juristen Gedanken gemacht, wie man dieses Gesetz angreifen kann.
Haben die richtigen Leute gefunden, für denen das auch schadet und haben jetzt eben diese Verfassungsbeschwerde eingereicht äh im Namen von,
eben ja der Reporter ohne Grenzen und dann eben dieser sieben,
Journalisten und Menschenrechtler und dann werden wir jetzt mal sehen, äh wie das weitergeht.
Viel Glück. Wäre berichten dann in ein paar Jahren wieder, wenn sich wenn sich mal jemand äh dessen angenommen hat.
So, Trojaner.
Staatstrianer ist im Einsatz.
Ist das eine News.
Na ja ähm das Bundeskriminalamt setzt jetzt Staatstrojaner für Smartphones bereits in aktuell laufenden Ermittlungsverfahren ein,
Und das ist natürlich äh eine eine News. Hier äh herausgebrochen von ähm wenn ich mich nicht täusche, Hakantan Riverdi, würde oft bei der Süddeutschen,
und Heiko Pinkert. Ähm.
Ja, die jetzt auch, nein, nicht viel mehr machen als es zu erklären. Und die äh die Kritik,
daran natürlich auch nochmal formulieren und sagen, na ja, das ist hier eine ein sehr großer Grundrechtseingriff, wo wir wissen, sehr wenig davon
ja? Und die Frage ist, welche, welche Software nutzen sie denn da, ja? Welche Geräte infizieren sie denn da? Bedienen sie sich da vielleicht ähm.
Der Software aus dem Hause Gamma, die eigentlich eher in in Unrechtsregimen zum zum Bekämpfen der Opposition, zum Einsatz kommt oder die zumindest von einem Unternehmen vertrieben wird, was auch kein Problem hat in diese Länder zu liefern,
ja ähm äh auch da ist eine Verfassungsbeschwerde äh geplant.
Und äh werden halt sehen, äh wie wir damit umgehen, aber ähm
wir wissen auch nicht, welche Infektionswege da jetzt genutzt werden und natürlich werden wir das auch so schnell nicht erfahren. Es sei denn, äh da äh liegt mal wieder etwas und jetzt natürlich einfach wieder ein ein,
schwerer,
größeres Problem, was entsprechend auch von ähm Heribert Branden in der Süddeutschen Zeitung dann auch nochmal mit der entsprechenden äh Schärfe,
äh kommentiert wird.
Wo kommt jetzt eigentlich das Ganze ist eine Meldung eigentlich der Esszelt, ne? Ähm.
Zwei Artikel gibt's dazu von aus der SZ, ja,
einmal den die Meldung als solche ja oder also die Meldung was heißt Melodie die der Bericht als solches und dann noch einer mit äh,
Reaktionen und darauf aus der aus der Politik. Ähm da gibt's auch eine Reaktion von mir. Im Namen des Chaos-Computerclubs.
So
Mache ich ja auch noch.
Ich habe ja sonst auch nichts zu tun. Ich sitze ja ganzen Tag hier Podcaste und mache äh mache Pressearbeit für Leben schönes Leben, ja.
Liebsten schönes Leben, ja. Wo bist du? So können wir nicht.
So kennen wir mich. So kenne ich mich. Schönes Leben, nix zu tun, genau.
Regierung kommt nicht voran, aber ähm es formuliere, es formulieren sich jetzt schon mal die Ausschüsse und ähm.
Da äh habe ich dann doch schmunzeln dürfen, da das darf man jetzt hier dann doch mal ähm.
Da werde ich dann doch mal zwei erwähnen. Also erstens, die FDP ist ja jetzt wieder im Bundestag und damit auch Jimmy Schulz,
der einer der ja ähm wie nennt man das profilierten Digitalpolitiker der FDP,
Der also das Thema Netzpolitik in der FDP seit äh ist das klingt immer wie FDP, ne? Wenn ich FDP sag.
Ja, tut es. Ich zucke auch hier. Das war so ein bisschen.
Weil ich glaube, dass ich da tatsächlich äh den Fehler mache. Jimmy Schulz hat äh.
Dieses Thema lange äh bearbeitet. Ähm.
Längere Zeit, er war auch mal in der Partei äh die Republikaner,
ja äh neunzehnhundertneunundachtzig sind Republikanern beigetreten und kandidierte für den Gemeinderat in Ottobrunn.
Und Kreistag. Er verließ die Partei nach einem Jahr wieder zweitausend erfolgte dann der Eintritt in die FDP. Äh nach der Kommunalwahl und so weiter,
Wie dem auch sei,
als Kinder waren wir alle scheiße jetzt durchaus jemand der nicht zu den Inkompetenten gehört in diesem Bereich und auch wenn ich das jetzt richtig gelesen habe ähm,
den Vorsitz im aus äh im Ausschuss Bundestagsausschuss digitale Agenda bekommt.
Den gibt's also wieder.
Den wird es wieder geben und das ist glaube ich gar nicht mal so schlecht,
wenn der äh wieder da ist. Er ist natürlich immer noch leider äh so beschnitten und nicht federführend für für seine Themen, sondern soll ja jetzt nun eine digital äh Strategie da formulieren.
Und ähm äh aber nicht tatsächlich diese dann auch eben in Gesetzesform umsetzen. Das ist natürlich zu äh bedauern,
aber ich denke, wir können uns freuen, dass wir den da wieder sehen. Genau, Jimmy Schulz ist der Vorsitzende dieses Ausschusses. Das ist,
erstmal keine schlechte Nachricht. Schlechte Nachricht.
Gab's denn sonst noch irgendwas? Ach so.
Ja, es gibt eine, es gibt eine schlechte Nachricht. Äh,
Oder na ja, das wird wurde in den Medien unterschiedlich rezipiert. Wir erinnern uns an den guten.
Herrn Brandt, ne? Stefan Brandner aus der AfD,
das ist der, der abends Biertrinken mit dem nicht abendländischen Dolch. Wir haben das damals klar kritisiert, dass es sich dabei nicht,
um ein traditionell deutsches Schneidgerät handelt, mit dem er die Antifa und das Zentrum frobelitische Schönheit in einem Tweet bedroht hat,
in dem auch gut sein äh Bierglas zu sehen war, dass sie ihn wahrscheinlich zu diesem Tweet motiviert hat,
dieser gute Herr ist nun.
In geheimer Wahl zum Vorsitzenden des Ausschusses für Recht und Verbraucherschutz gewählt worden,
In diesem Ausschuss gibt's dreiundvierzig Abgeordnete und er hat von diesen äh dreiundvierzig Abgeordneten neunzehn Ja-Stimmen bekommen,
jeweils zwölf nein Stimmen und Enthaltungen. Das heißt, er hat jetzt nicht unbedingt die Mehrheit, aber aufgrund der vielen Enthaltungen.
Und äh und dann eben prozentual nicht mehr ausreichend vielen Gegenstimmen ist ja jetzt der Vorsitzende,
Dieses Ausschusses. Das heißt jetzt auch nicht, also Ausschussvorsitz,
heißt halt, dass man die Sitzungsordnung macht, ja? Äh der der Einfluss, der Parteien richtet sich da nach dem Proports, insofern wird der jetzt nicht das Rechtssystem in Deutschland vor die Hunde fahren können. Ähm,
und entsprechend wurde äh diese äh beiden Ausschussvorsitze, die jetzt die AfD in Ausschüssen des Deutschen Bundestages hat auch als ja parlamentarische Stärke,
rezipiert in einigen Medien. Ähm! Die eben sagen nun es ist Usus, dass diese Ausschussvorsitzende werden eben verteilt,
und das geht da streng rein um, sonst hätten wir auch zum Beispiel niemals in Berlin das Glück gehabt, dass
Martin Delius, der bei uns ja auch schon zu Gast war als Pirat dann eben den Untersuchungsausschuss vorsitzt
der die das BER-Desaster auseinander nimmt, weil das eben da streng rein umgeht und äh da eben jeder mal drankommt und,
Das ist eben ist im Prinzip einfach nur mehr Arbeit.
Also wir haben jetzt hier diesen Typ mit der Machete und solange der sein Bier und die Machete äh zu Hause lässt, solange der in den Ausschuss kommt äh,
Ist das vielleicht auch tatsächlich äh ein Zeichen der parlamentarischen Stärke, denn es wurde argumentiert.
Das eben hier nicht der dem die AfD wieder ihre Underdog-Position bekommt.
Na ja klar, die wollen auch ihre Opferrolle da irgendwie.
Müssen jetzt mal aus ihrer Opferrolle raus, ja? Denn jetzt ist nicht mehr nur äh Bundes, jetzt ist nicht mehr nur die da oben, die da oben, sondern ihr seid jetzt die da oben
Und jetzt müsst ihr es anders machen, aber könnt zumindest nicht mehr sagen, oh, ihr habt einen Maulkorb und so weiter, sondern inzwischen ist die,
äh ihre Maulkorbe, Körbe äh verordnet dieses Jahr inzwischen schon selber, die haben sich jetzt irgendwie wie so ein Kegelclub, ne? So Regeln, interne Regeln gemacht. Die AfD-Fraktion hat jetzt interne Regeln irgendwie gegen Pöbeln,
Hast du gelesen,
Die haben sich so in Köppen und so einen unterirdischen Umgang miteinander, dass die jetzt äh sich quasi gegenseitig da äh dass die sich jetzt auf so ein, dass sie sich einigen mussten,
wie miteinander umzugehen ist.
Wie man als Mensch so normalerweise nein, ich äh muss äh.
Gelesen. Der wie man al.
Also ich ich habe seit der Wahl ehrlich gesagt diesen Bundestag nicht wahrgenommen. Ist ja eigentlich irgendwas, ich meine was machen die denn da jetzt eigentlich die ganze Zeit? Beschließen die.
Ja, die haben jetzt zum Beispiel diese Ausschüsse formuliert. Vom Bild ist doch schön.
Na ja gut, ich meine, ist ja auch schon Februar, ist ja schon fast alles ein halbes Jahr her. Also ich meine, kommt dieser Bundestag überhaupt in Wallung? Ich meine, wird da überhaupt irgendwas beschlossen.
Ach, weiß der Geier. Ich war.
Ich meine, man könnte doch jetzt auch irgendwas ist jetzt nicht so, dass es den nicht gibt.
Ich suche gerade das Artikel raus zu diesem äh zu den zu diesen Verhaltens. Also sie haben jetzt, die haben auf jeden Fall wie so ein wie so ein äh wie so ein Kegelverein, weißt du?
Tja, nee, aber das, ich meine.
Schon das Material.
Ist nicht schön ist nicht schön jetzt irgendwie diese AfD Erfolg aber jetzt sind sie halt da. Jetzt müssen wir irgendwie auch mit klarkommen und ich schätze mal es könnte noch ganz unterhaltsam werden.
Also.
Es könnte ganz unterhaltsam werden und wenn ich die Wahl vor die Wahl gestellt ob ich jetzt so ein.
Menschen, der sich die ganze Zeit als irgendwie die da oben sind Scheiße, aber uns lassen sie nicht und hier Meinungsdiktatur und äh und so weiter und Lügenpresse und so weiter. Dem tut man doch nicht den Gefallen. Ähm,
ihn dann auch noch an dieser,
diesen Vorsitz da zu verwehren, damit er nach Hause gehen kann. Bier trinkt und twittert hier die undemokratischen Parteien, ja? Und,
Dann kriegt er jetzt eben den Sack Arbeit, da wird er schon sehen, wie das da oben ist. Bei aller Liebe ist das eben auch viel Arbeit.
Aber auch genug. Äh insofern kann man's mal sehen. Er sagte, er wolle sich darauf äh beschränken, den Ausschuss möglichst objektiv zu leiten,
und politische Äußerung seien Fraktionskollegen zu überlassen.
Ja, ist doch gut.
Ja, ist doch gut. Denn das ist gut, dann lass die mal Politik machen und du leitest, du leitest da den Ausschuss, da wirst du genug mit zu tun haben.
Insofern ja ich muss da nochmal kurz drauf eingehen. Also natürlich ist das irgendwie jetzt kein nicht schön, gerade diese, gerade der Rechtsausschuss ist natürlich einer, der für uns hier auch ein Lokbuch Netzpolitik eine eine Rolle spielen wird in den nächsten vier Jahren,
Das ist einer der wichtigsten Ausschüsse für uns. Ähm natürlich ist das jetzt keine Ziele, wenn da jemand von der AfD den Vorsitz hat. Ähm.
Aber die Mehrheit hat nach wie vor, was auch immer, die nächste Koalition sein wird.
Wer auch immer eine Regierungskoalition formt, äh wird am Ende da die Gesetze durchboxen und da hat eben so ein Ausschussvorsitz auch wenig,
Einfluss drauf. Ähm!
Und damit so viel Respekt müssen wir dann eben leider auch vor der Demokratie haben, dass wenn die AfD da reingewählt wird, dass äh die eben dann auch da in den an den parlamentarischen Prozessen,
gemäß den Geflogenheiten mit Arbeit zugeschüttet wird.
Würden sie denn jetzt mal was machen? Irgendwie, jetzt haben sie geredet, haben sie jetzt genug, jetzt äh sind sie da, wo sie hinwollten, jetzt hören sie mal zeigen, dass sie äh äh eins und eins zusammenzählen können. Ich bin mir da ehrlich gesagt noch nicht so ganz so sicher, aber ich lasse mich überraschen.
Es war eine wunderschöne Überleitung.
Also.
Wir blicken ja jetzt schon auch mit einigen Jahren auf diesen Netzaktivismus,
zurück. Und ich habe ja auch mal,
Früher bei Netzpolitik Ork geschrieben. Und ich kann eigentlich sagen, dass.
Das waren ja noch ganz andere Zeiten. Wir haben jetzt zweitausendachtzehn. Ich glaube, ich war zweitausendzehn bei Netzpolitik Ork angestellt.
Ja, bis dich abgeworben habe.
Abgeworben hat, mich äh abgeworben hat, mich eine Security-Bude, aber,
Also vom Haupteinkommen her. Aber ja äh weil ich da das traf sich sehr gut, weil ich das Hobby der Netzpolitik damals natürlich halten wollte. Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Wir freuen uns immer, wenn unsere Äußerungen Einzug in das politische Denken.
Der Bundesrepublik erhalten? Sei es äh zum Beispiel auch, wenn ein AfD-Politiker,
eine Rede hält, die zu großen Teilen von Netzpolitik Org abgeschrieben wurde,
Und zwar in diesem Fall von einem äh von einem Artikel von Ingo Dachwitz, der ja auch hier schon zu Gast war und der inzwischen seid, ah der ist jetzt auch schon seit Jahren bei Netzpolitik Org. Und ähm,
behandelt da ja unter anderem hier die Eprivacy Richtlinie, zu der er auch beim Kongress vorgetragen hat. Äh
ein guter Mann und der hat natürlich jetzt auch den Ritterschlag bekommen, das aus seinem Artikel hier so gute anderthalb äh DIN A vier Seiten wortwörtlich äh,
mit winzigen Änderungen von dem AfD-Politiker Christoph Krim im Bundestag verlesen wurden.
Leider leider, leider, ohne vorher zu sagen, wie Ingo Dachwitz, wie der Weise Ingo Dachwitz schon schrieb, letztes Jahr, sondern einfach so, als wären seine eigenen Worte. Äh der.
AfD Abgeordnete äh formulierte dann dazusiades hätte wohl der Praktikant in aller Eile geschrieben,
Und ähm man hätte ihm ja außerdem nur äh kurz vorher äh gesagt, dass er das müsste und so weiter,
Aber äh Ingwer hat sich relativ viel Zeit gelassen, darauf zu antworten und ich dachte schon so.
Ob er jetzt auch sagt, der Gentleman gegießt und schweigt? Nein
Er hat sich einfach nur Zeit gelassen mit seiner Antwort und die Replik kann man da durchaus mal lesen, weil er natürlich dann sagt, ja hier, außer dem falsch, im falschen Kontext wiedergegeben, falscher Schluss daraus gezogen ähm,
Übrigens stehen unsere Artikel unter äh CCBI, NCSA und das damit hat er hier eine Lizenzverletzung begangen. Einfach äh sehr schön ist A ähm,
und äh sagt rechtliche Schritte könnten wir Unternehmen, aber äh ist der Aufwand einfach nicht nicht wert. Und äh wir werden unsere Ressourcen eher äh auf die kritische Berichterstattung,
konzentrieren, aber er sagt, was bleibt die AfD? Die AfD macht gern mit Polemik gegen vermeintlich faule und zu gut bezahlte Abgeordnete Stimmung.
Dabei schafft sie es in diesem Fall eines, dabei schafft sie es in diesem Fall,
schafft es in diesem Fall eine ihrer Protagonisten nicht einmal eine Rede ordentlich abzuschreiben. Wir sehen einen AfD-Politiker, der eine Rede zu einem Thema hält, mit dem er sich offensichtlich nicht auseinandergesetzt hat. Der lange Palavert
ohne überhaupt eine Position zu beziehen, der für sein Amt bezahlt wird und Mitarbeiter hat, aber bei anderen abschreibt
der keine politische Verantwortung für sein Handeln übernimmt und als Entschuldigung nur dumm gelaufen sagt. Peinlicher geht es kaum,
Und äh dieses Zeugnis der Doppelmoral sollen sich alle zu Gemüte führen, die behaupten, die AfD trage etwas zur Lösung. Der Probleme bei. Treffer versenkt.
Ingo Dachwitz, vielen Dank.
Und ansonsten freuen wir uns. Ja, man muss aber auch ganz ehrlich sagen, wir da wir freuen uns, wenn die Inhalte hier ähm.
Dass wir ähm ja was Herr Geier, also vielleicht schaffen wir es ja auch mit unseren Sendungen noch direkt im Bundestag. Jetzt hatten wir einfach mal so ein bisschen staatstragender daherreden.
Vielleicht könnte der Herr Brandner ja einfach zur ersten Sitzung des Rechtsausschusses einfach mal Tagesordnungspunkt eins.
Wie Herr Neumann schon sagte.
Wir hören jetzt mal Lokbuchnetzpolitik.
Einfach direkt ab.
Zum Staatstrojaner.
Genau, wir machen einfach so eine so eine Sendung, die einfach nur so aus Beispielreden hält. Äh äh besteht,
so für verschiedene ähm auch für verschiedene Couleur, also mit konservativem Anstrich oder so mit so links ähm sozialistischen Tombola.
Du, als wir vor, ich überlege gerade, wie viele Jahre das jetzt schon her ist, als wir mit Ulf zusammen digitale Gesellschaft damals den ähm.
Den Gesetzes äh Copy and Paste Vorlage für einen Gesetzesentwurf zur ähm Abschaffung der Störerhaftung,
formuliert haben. Da hat da haben wir tatsächlich das wie so ein Gesetzesentwurf formuliert und äh gesagt, hier bitteschön, den spenden wir,
könnt ihr nehmen und einfach umsetzen,
und das war durchaus auch ernst gemeint. Natürlich müssen unsere Inhalte irgendwie da wiederhalt finden. Da dafür machen wir die ganze Theater doch. Leider am Ende.
Ja. Wisst ihr eigentlich am Ende auch dann so übernommen worden.
Nee, die die tatsächliche Ausgestaltung war eine andere, aber muss man auch sagen ähm,
Das Thema Störerhaftung abschaffen hat es ja dann doch über die Jahre,
gehalten und uns wurde ja jetzt mehrfach versprochen mit Nachbesserung und so weiter, jetzt haben wir die Steuerhaftung abgeschafft, jetzt aber wirklich da hat der lange Atem äh,
gehalten, aber inzwischen haben wie ich auch traurig feststellen muss, Ulfe und ich halt auch graue Haare bekommen.
Ja, ich habe festgestellt, hier sieht's, gut bei dir ist jetzt auch.
Oh Gott. Vorbei.
Bei Ulf weiß ich noch nicht mal, ob der schon grau hat.
Der kriegt noch welche Kanal. Keine Sorge. Hat genug Projekte umgebaut.
Der zupft ihn noch. Ulf, gib aus, gib auf. Nein, Quatsch. Da haben wir eben äh.
Also manchmal freuen wir uns,
aber wenn in der Regel wird's dann eben auch zitiert. Somit äh könnten wir noch auf die Cabinet-Falts eingehen, aber das ist eigentlich nur so ein kleiner Lacher am Rande, oder?
Ja, ist ein kleiner Lacher am Rande. Aber für Lacher am Rande sind wohl ja sind wir immer zu haben.
Haben.
Ja, also ein Lieg der besonderen Art. Das äh fand mich jetzt äh statt in Australien und Histories für dieser Hardcore. Da hat da so eine Behörde.
Als Mobil versteigert,
Was sie nicht mehr brauchte. Stühle, Tische, alles Mögliche. Und äh unter anderem war da auch so ein Schrank dabei.
Ein Cabinet, wie man so schön sagt und ähm das war verschlossen und es kriegten sie nicht mehr auf, weil sie irgendwie den Schlüssel dafür nicht mehr hatten. Und dann haben sie irgendwie beschlossen.
Günstiger abgeben.
Ding einfach so komplett mit, hier könnt ihr so haben, kriegen wir eh nicht mehr auf und so weiter.
Der ist noch gut, von außen noch gut.
Da geht noch was. Na ja, dann ist es irgendwie in die Finger von ähm einer Zeitung, die ich jetzt nicht genau weiß, welche äh gekommen,
Die haben das Ding einfach mal gekauft für wenig Geld und haben dann irgendwie, wie man das so macht, einfach mal einen Bohrer angesetzt und das Ding irgendwie aufgedrillt
Stellte sich raus, dass das Seil von unten bis oben voll war mit irgendwie top Secret Papers. Über alle möglichen Details, Einschätzung von Politikern irgendwie Australien und so weiter und haben das Ganze jetzt äh wunderbar auch auf einer Webseite gefick
äh geliegt und dann äh passenderweise genannt, was natürlich sehr lustig ist, weil's halt sowohl äh Einblicke in das äh australische Kabinett äh gibt
als eben auch aus einem solchen entstammt. Und das fand ich dann doch irgendwie auch mal so eine ganz neuen schönen Angriffsvektor.
Was haben sieben, sieben Stories einfach mal so schon raus, ne?
Ja, also
einige Sachen raus so haarsträubende Geschichten, Einschätzungen, irgendwie, dass Leute, dass sie auch selber irgendwelche Dokumente verpeilen und irgendwie gar nicht mehr wissen, was sie da tun. Also es äh erfordert, ich hatte so ein bisschen quer gelesen, aber es äh erfordert sagen wir mal auch so eine gewisse Grundkenntnis australischer Politik, also insbesondere in Bezug auf Namen, äh die
so
Leider auch fehl.
Da bin ich nur so im Ansatz äh äh dabei, die haben ja bisher noch nicht genug Abstrahlungsenergie, um da wirklich mal interessant zu sein, aber vielleicht ändert sich das jetzt auch
wenn da sozusagen noch mehr spaßiger äh Kram rauskommt. Da fliegen die Kühe ja auch tief, also.
Sag mal da ist doch aber jetzt auch eine Arbeitslos geworden, oder? Du musst doch, wenn du so einen Schrank verkaufst, musst du den Leuten, das sagt dir doch das Team, was den hochhebt, dass der ein bisschen schwer ist.
Ja, also ob die Person, die schon die Instruktion bekommen hat, die jetzt mal zu entfernen, schon entschuldige ist, also.
Nee, der, wer auch immer gesagt hat, hau weg.
Ja wer auch immer da mal Top Secret Papers reingelegt hat und den Schlüssel verlegt hat, also ich meine das.
Das ist doch nicht das Problem, das das hätten sie doch lösen können, das konnte die Zeitung doch auch lösen mit einem mit dem Bohrer.
Nee, klar, aber offensichtlich hat sich ja zu dem Zeitpunkt schon niemand mehr darum gekümmert oder um wir auch nur ein Wissen, also man wusste ja schon gar nicht mehr, was mit diesem Schrank überhaupt ist. Also das ist die komplette Inventur hat versagt.
Sind die Vorzüge der EDV Tim.
Ja, ja.
Speicherst du das schön ab und dann machst du nach drei Jahren eh ein Cleaning Store und die Scheiße ist.
Ladet die Festplatte aufm aufm Müll irgendwie. Das könnte auch nochmal ganz putzig werden.
Ah ja, das äh das ist auch, kann ich auch nur empfehlen, wenn ihr mal, wenn ihr euch mal langweilig ist, kauft da mal eine Festplatte. Eine gebrauchte Festplatte,
und stellt die Daten wieder her. Aber ihr müsst die Festplatten nehmen, wo ihr auf dem Foto seht, dass da eine Inventarnummer drauf ist oder sowas oder ein altes Lap.
Weil die sind interessant sozusagen, ja?
Na ja, weil die kommen aus Unternehmensbeständen, da sind natürlich dann interessantere Daten drauf,
hab ich auch schon ein Laptop mal gekauft, sehr schön. Große Freude Inventarnummer draufgekauft, zack alle Dateien wieder hergestellt und hab Spaß gehabt.
Sag nicht, welches Unternehmen das war. Vor allem das Laptop gibt's danach einfach wieder ab.
Ja, Doppelt Spaß.
Durch oder.
Ja aber Tim der Schrank dahinten, ne? Brauchst du den noch?
Ja, ja, man kann vieles streng gehaltene Dokumente drin.
Die Geheimlogo Netzpolitik Dokumente. Jo, wir melden uns sehr zeitnah wieder. Mit einem LMP Spezial, wie schon angekündigt, zum besonderen elektronischen Anwaltspostfach.
Also man soll ja nicht immer so Sendungen äh in Aussicht stellen.
Genau das soll man, weil man dann den sozialen Druck hat, die auch zu machen.
Den haben wir eh also ich schon, was dies mit dir ist.
Ich habe einen Inneren dran. Ich habe einen, ich muss, mich zieht's an den Podcast. Ja, nur noch dummes.
Wir sind schon über zwei Stunden hierhin, nur noch dummes Zeug. Ähm wir machen jetzt hier einfach mal Schluss. Äh ist schon viel zu spät. Vielen Dank äh fürs Dabeibleiben, wieder äh mitmachen in diesem Jahr.
Vielen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit.
Genau. Wir werden dann auch äh ein bisschen fokussierter sein. Aber wir mussten uns heute auch erst vor der Sendung erstmal drei Stunden lang.
Drei Stunden lang in den Armen liegen, weil wir uns so vermisst haben.
Och Gott, das war so. Der Mann hatte einen gewissen Informationsaustauschbedarf, der muss erstmal befriedigt werden. Deswegen sind wir jetzt schon viel zu lange hier am Tisch und sagen tschüss, bis bald.
Vielen herzlichen Dank, bis denn, ciao ciao.